Doo,
Doo Doo Doo
two.
All right.
Kyle Kingsbury,
Hawaiian brother.
I'm doing great brother.
I have a present for you.
This is a legit fanny pack.
Look at that because your a fanny pack
enthusiast.
He's one of the few manly men than I can
count upon to almost always be wearing a
fanny pack.
Wow.
Look at that baby.
That's a higher primate dotcom special.
Oh,
this is phenomenal.
I wanted to get one of these back in the
day.
And you were out of stock.
Yeah,
that's right.
Quite some time because that fucking
sell out of these things.
Believe it or not.
I believe that these are made by roots
and they have like a.
The pocket is got a higher primate.com,
like things stamped into it,
but it's fucking high level baby.
I found out about that one from dice
clay came in,
he's another fanny pack,
enthusiastic.
I love dies.
And he had sweatpants on and uh,
he was wearing this beautiful leather
fanny pack and I was like,
where did you get that?
Oh,
so roots one,
it's the best.
And they took it off and showed it to me
were like,
you know,
girls will like look at each other's
persons.
That's what we were doing.
Oh yeah.
You inspected the pockets.
You wanted to say this is,
where is my wallet?
My cell phone can go.
This is where my chapstick will go.
So I bought one.
It's legit as fuck.
And then after I bought it,
um,
I was uh,
I was so in love with and I was like,
they make these for me and put my stamp
on it.
And they said yes.
So the zipper pocket,
if you look at it,
it has the higher primates stamp with
the champ of the light bulb above his
head.
Pretty Sweet,
Huh?
Yeah.
This is amazing.
Look with the one you're wearing,
bro,
is like,
it screams,
hiker.
Screams hitchhiker.
It is.
I got this pack safe.
I got this before.
Go into central and South America
because you can lock the zippers so
people can't get into it.
Can't pick pocket.
Yeah.
Cables on the,
uh,
on the band.
They're like steel cables so they can't
cut them.
Rarely do like a lot of slash and grab
stuff over there.
I guess.
Jesus Christ.
Let me see this thing.
You've got my ma.
I need to change brands.
Survival pack.
It's back.
This might travel.
Wait,
so you could do curls with the travel.
and this has a chords in it when you
feel to have them little cords,
you can't cut it.
Heavy duty ratable.
Oh my goodness.
And when you,
when you click that in there,
there's a three buttons to open it up.
Not your normal two button action.
Oh yeah.
One,
two and three.
This is legit.
They got the RF R I r I f,
D Rfd,
Card radio frequency.
So if you're passing by and some little
hackers on his laptop,
he can't steal all your apple pay
information from your iphone and shit
like that.
Someone can do that.
Fuck yeah.
Just walking by you.
Haven't you seen rogue nation?
Try not to.
I tried to try to stay as far out of the
loop with all these fucking hacker
wipper.
Stanford.
What does this bad boy is?
So that's where you click all those
three together.
You put a lock on it.
I see.
Dude,
this is impressive stuff.
They made it out of Calvin bar.
It'd be even better.
Cover your Dick.
You know,
they make clothes now out of Kevlar that
they look like regular clothes,
but you can take a bullet with him,
like how it's going to fall.
It would penetrate you slightly and then
come out and feel awesome.
Yeah.
But it's going to keep the from going
through into your body.
It'll hurt.
What do you think that would feel like?
It depends on the round,
but uh,
it wouldn't feel good.
It's,
I've,
I've talked to people that have been
shot with bulletproof vests that say say
it's like getting punched.
But.
So are these plates like in pants and
shit like that?
Or is this like some type of material
that's moveable?
It's both.
They have some of them,
they even have some that prevent you
from knife attacks.
They have like a,
a thick Mesh Kevlar that seems more
real.
Kind of like a chain mail.
The bad guy wears in commando.
Yeah.
There's a,
uh,
there was a vice documentary or vice
piece on this guy who is known for
making bulletproof close.
He's a tailor,
I want to say Columbia,
I think he's in Bogota,
but he's,
um,
he's known for making like really nice
clothes that just happened to be
bulletproof.
Like the whole deal underwear,
everything.
That's pretty bad ass.
That's pretty bad.
That's like the kingsmen guy as I said.
Yeah.
Here you go.
Israeli reporter testing and knife proof
vest ends up getting stabbed.
Well,
well that's not good.
he actually got stabbed all the way
through or just a little bit.
Oh Jesus Christ.
This is a commando knife and he's just
gonna fucking stab him with this thing.
Is this guy doing sign language in the
lower left?
Oh,
that's hilarious.
You wouldn't pick up the stab here.
Penetrating through.
We,
I missed.
He said,
yeah,
fucking dudes going to be bleeding.
That dude downplayed it pretty well for
getting stabbed.
Yeah.
He,
uh,
took it.
He took it quite easily.
Jesus Christ.
I guess it works I guess a little bit.
Yeah,
I mean it's definitely better than not
having that on.
He would be dead works sometimes.
It works a little bit.
It was like step me like this.
That'll live in color.
Your stay here to be like this.
Well,
you've seen those martial arts
demonstrations with those guys.
Do that.
Like come at you with a knife.
The other guy,
the stabbing technique.
Always.
Yeah.
They say that the best way to knife
fight is actually to put your arm
forward.
You wrap your clothes or on your arm and
put a knife in your back hand.
Meanwhile,
why the fuck do I know what the best way
to knife fight is?
What are the odds you're ever going to
get in a knife fight like you and
another guy on the beach like circling
each other with a knife and your jacket
wrapped around your forearm and b,
it starts playing to town.
Oh No,
no,
no.
Yeah,
that's right.
They were switchblades right?
They had a little knife fight.
They were tied together.
People just do knife fights in the
movies.
Remember those.
That was a big thing in movies and been
back in the
old musicals.
What was that?
A West side story there.
They did Saturday night fever.
Have a knife fight.
It did,
right.
They had a knife fight too.
What the fuck is wrong with people back
then?
All the cocaine.
Is that what it was?
I don't know.
What did the cocaine kick can?
It was in the eighties,
right?
I think it was around in the seventies
and it just got giant in the eighties.
Have you watched narcos?
No,
but I hear it's awesome to actually.
Eddie Bravo to always talks about how
it's just.
Yeah,
he's hooked.
He got me.
He got me hooked and now I'm hooked.
I'm trying to spread the world,
spread it to the world.
We're looking for new shows.
It's a fucking awesome show,
man.
It's incredible.
It's really,
really nuts.
So it was a documentary style or.
No,
it's um,
there's some real footage of uh,
the actual med,
a in cartel and you know,
there's some real footage of like the
different busts and some murder footage.
Some bodies that they really real,
real,
um,
like some of the horrible atrocities
they committed.
They,
they show you real footage of that.
But for the most part it just is the
story of Pablo Escobar and his rise to
power.
That's right.
It is fucking bad ass dude.
It's so dope.
They just did such a good job.
Netflix just as Netflix.
Yeah.
Okay.
They have so much fucking money,
man.
They can,
they can put together these things and
make them like,
like 10 movies,
you know,
it's like ten one hour movies.
That's the best.
I can't really.
We have trouble watching regular tv now.
Like hbo kind of spoiled us.
You watch a show.
I mean even though the beauty of Netflix
is that you get it all at once,
so the whole season,
but even still like we're watching
dexter back in the day or.
And there was really only a few good
seasons there,
but you know,
whatever show that's on that,
that you can watch straight through with
no commercials and no fast forwarding.
Yeah.
Night and day better than having to use
the dvr and sit through the commercials.
This just,
that's caveman shit's.
It's terrible.
It's old days.
Those are the old days were done with
the commercial.
They need to come up with a new way to
sell you shit,
you know,
like interrupting TV shows.
It just makes me not want to buy their
stuff.
There was some new comedy on tbs.
I don't know why we were watching it,
but they kept showing Ford ads during
the show and they were trying.
They would make like a little chime,
like pong and then they would have this
giant Ford.com on the bottom.
Like they were trying to do it so
blatant that it was humorous,
but at the same time it was like fucking
irking me.
Like what was this ridiculous?
It was some new comedy on tbs,
some cheese Dick,
a cop show.
So while the show is on the,
the commercials playing over the
dialogue and all that stuff would just
go home and then you'd see this thing
like superimposed over the bottom of the
screen for Daca and was repeated though.
Like,
I mean,
after the commercials you see this just
pop up and they're like,
this is the future of TV.
Then we're like that.
That's what they're doing to try to
counter dvrs.
Just stick it even more in your face.
It's fucking gross,
man.
Just over the top with it.
So stupid.
It's such a dumb way to advertise.
They just have to figure out a better
way to let people know about their shit,
you know?
Just some,
some cool way.
That's not the way to do it,
but that's neither here nor there.
No,
I love saying that.
I never get to know their heritage.
So Dude,
I'm on that diet.
I'm on the ketogenic diet now or trying
to get into it and you know,
you talking about it with me sort of
inspired me a little bit because one of
the big things a lot of people are
saying you can't be.
You can't do explosive activities.
Bullshit.
Kyle Kingsbury's punk and you fucking
nerds.
Oh,
you nutrition nerds.
I'll tell you what,
man,
if you get into any sort of a diet
online or tell people you're gonna,
try something.
The fucking experts come so many people.
Even when that's why I deleted my
facebook account,
I just couldn't stand over the years in
the UFC.
I just would say,
oh sure,
yeah,
I allow you to be friends with.
I need to be friends.
That kind of thing.
And then over time you've got 5,000
people that think through your pals,
like at least on twitter,
I follow who I want to follow.
That's that.
I'm not subscribed to any of their shit.
You know,
one point 7 million people following you
online on twitter alone,
you know,
you post,
you're going to do this and people come
out the woodwork about it.
I would write about like,
oh,
I just read this book.
It's phenomenal.
Check it out.
You know?
And then everybody's got to come up with
this.
So here's a article I found online.
I will send you the link and this guy's
a total wack job.
He's an idiot.
This like this.
Like this one paragraph somebody wrote,
it's going to totally dispel and throw
out the window what this guy spent years
researching and putting together in his
book.
Yeah.
It's always like Vegan news.com.
You're like,
oh,
Jesus sits on a real source of dare you.
But um,
this,
uh,
this diet,
I,
so I've been on it now only for four
days.
This is today I think is the fourth,
third or fourth day,
let's call it the third day,
third day,
100 percent.
And uh,
I had headaches unlike the,
somewhere around the second day I
started getting a little bit ahead of.
I read that on your instagram,
but it's got a fix for it.
What's the fix?
So a lot of people,
when they transition low carb,
they have,
there's a window before you start
producing ketones on your own,
right?
You can jumpstart that window with
fasting,
which is a total pain in the ass,
especially if you're carbohydrate
dependent or you can cheat it by using
mct oil.
So if you up your MCTs,
the first three days kind of borderline
where you might shoot yourself,
then you have,
you totally negate any of that really
feeling like groggy.
Like I don't have the energy or fuck
man,
I can't move like you,
you can eliminate that completely with
MCTs.
Why does mct oil make you shit yourself?
Because it does.
It does.
And I'm not going to lie.
Uh,
I've shipped myself at least five times
in the past two years as an adult.
Some drunk milk I don't drink anymore,
but yeah.
What was it?
The mcts.
I got a little cocky,
you know,
like I know I measure everything out
religiously now.
I mean,
but in this,
everything's fine tuning.
It's all personal process.
I had to start with a teaspoon.
Now I'm up to four tablespoons per pot
of coffee.
I make a whole pot blended up with a two
to one ratio of kerrygold butter to the
MCT oil.
Then I have my little Stevia drops,
that kind of thing.
If I'm on the road,
I got other stuff,
but I don't.
I used to,
if I was on the road and I'm having
coffee,
I would just take a gulp of mct Nixon.
You bring your own whipping cream here.
What is that heavy cream?
Yeah,
you got to get on it bro.
Unless you don't have a.
If you don't have a lot of heavy cream.
Got to get on it,
bro.
You got to Stevia drops here.
Just like Jim Carrey does.
What's the,
just like Jim Carrey,
Jim Carrey has stevia drops a everyone
go check out the.
The coffee.
What does the coffee in cars with
comedians.
Oh,
he brings Stevia drops or the.
He does it when he's out with Seinfeld.
It's awesome.
So.
So tell me why do you have heavy
whipping cream?
Well,
no,
this is,
first of all is mark sisson detail
earlier.
This is grass fed free range.
All good stuff.
I don't have a lactose intolerant or a
dairy intolerance.
So that's,
let's iron that out right now.
I don't recommend this to anybody who
does.
Um,
but this is a way to get more fat.
And that's really what you're trying to
do.
We'd as natural people from a primal
standpoint when in periods of Ketosis,
no matter where we were on planet earth,
so I know you were talking about the
other day,
like what is this ancestral diet stuff,
that kind of stuff that's based on where
you live.
So if you had ancestors from the Poles,
then you likely had big game and fruits
and vegetables and things that grew in
colder climates,
you know,
like Kale and shit like that.
If you were by the equator,
smaller stuff,
smaller live animals like chicken,
fish,
those kinds of things and then much more
carbohydrates,
but both,
no matter where you were from,
you had periods where you didn't eat.
So that's someone you'd produce your own
ketones to remain in a ketogenic state.
He really do have to have a much higher
level of fat and people think like way
more to where you.
It's counterintuitive,
especially with cholesterol and things
like that.
But the research is out.
I mean these guys are putting together
things.
Uh,
Dr David Perlmutter wrote Grain Brain in
2013.
He had researched from 2013 and 2012 and
2011 all in the book in Twenty 15.
He followed up with brain maker.
Brand new studies are being put in that
book.
So this is like the very latest and what
they're showing across the board is for
all the mental disorders like
Alzheimer's,
dementia,
Parkinson's,
they all have to do with a really high
blood sugar levels over time.
So one person might manifest as type two
diabetes and other person might get
Alzheimer's.
It's just your genetic coding.
That's the genetic difference.
Eating like Shit's going to get you to
have that disease,
you know,
manifest itself.
It's just sugar itself seems to be just
really,
really bad.
It's a bad deal.
Yeah.
So.
But as you'll find it's really easy to
eat too much protein on the Diet and
that can knock you out of ketosis.
So really getting too much protein
knocks you out of Ketosis.
There's a,
there's a process the body does called
gluconeogenesis and this is kind of
where Atkins failed a lot of people.
Even my dad was,
oh,
dot koons.
I lost weight and what I felt like,
Shit,
you know,
I have this pain across my chest and
they call it like Atkins fever.
Feel like flu symptoms,
right?
Right.
That comes from what's your,
what's your energy source?
So if people do a low carb diet and they
think,
well,
I don't want to have too much fat
because that's not healthy and they
don't understand good fats and bad fats.
So they say,
okay,
well I'll just stop my protein to fill
up and I'll have a little bit of fat and
low carb.
Well now your body has to take protein
and turn it back into glucose and that's
what gluconeogenesis does and it's a
very you,
your body will do it,
but it's not an easy thing to do.
Fat and carbohydrates are much,
much easier as energy sources.
So if you can keep protein moderate,
that's why now modified Atkins or
ketogenic diets,
they'll tell you it's high fat,
moderate protein,
low carb.
So when you say like moderate,
like how many grams,
grams of protein do you get in a day?
That's all individual for anybody.
You know,
if you're working out how you work out
you about to 20,
something like that.
I went to 25 right now.
I probably have,
I don't know,
definitely under 140 grams of protein.
Really?
That's interesting because I'm.
The bodybuilder method was one gram per
pound at least,
and they were doing six,
seven meals a day.
Look the.
So if you're were putting on size,
I'm not going to tilt.
Dorian Yates how to put on size.
Like he,
they,
they eat that way specifically for gains
and that is scientifically proven to
help with gains.
You're eating like a child basically.
You have a newborn.
They eat every two hours.
They're,
they're eating everything.
Carbohydrates,
protein and fat.
Right?
So when you want to gain size,
that's the way to do it.
But for this you don't necessarily need
that.
And you can employ different methods
like intermittent fasting where they
talk about skip breakfast and just eat
between 12 and seven.
You're not that protein window of Oh my,
my nitrogen balance is lowering.
I'm going to lose muscle mass.
It's total crap.
They will tell you,
oh,
you skip a meal,
you're gonna,
you're gonna.
Get weak,
bro.
Total crap.
All the hormones that give us,
um,
recovery,
anything like that,
igf one and growth hormone,
they all go through the roof when we
donate.
So the longer we fast the hierarchy,
ketone production is the hierarchy.
Anti catabolic hormones are so their
muscle preserving.
Now you could do a fast incorrectly and
you know,
you go run a wrong long race or,
or if you did high intensity stuff
fasted then yeah,
you'd be running into problems there
with that because that's autolysis
right?
Your body starts to break down muscle
tissue.
Is that what it's called?
Autolysis because you're working.
Glycolytic.
This is all right in there in the primal
endurance book.
But Marxist,
I got the pick that up right after it
was on the show.
Yeah,
I didn't.
Neil Kendall,
I really enjoyed talking to that guy.
That was.
Yeah,
that was a really cool conversation and
a very eyeopening.
You know,
one,
one thing that really opened my eyes are
really had me thinking was they've shown
on studies recently on children that
have epilepsy,
that putting them in a ketogenic state
seems to stop epileptic seizures or
significantly reduce them.
That's how the Diet was developed in the
19 twenties that I think it was John
Hopkins University or hospital,
not university,
Johns Hopkins,
whatever put together.
They had a team of guys there that
figured it out.
And um,
there's actually a guy
who was on the Tim Ferriss podcast.
Dr Dominic D'agostino,
who is awesome.
Yeah,
check him out.
He's out.
I heard that one.
South Florida.
He's fasted for seven days and then left
the house for 15 reps,
did five 85 or single,
then gave a lecture to 300 plus people
on fasting and ketogenic diets.
That guy's a trip.
He's,
he's really fascinating.
Super fucking intelligent now,
like you're listening to them talk about
it and how he travels with his own
exogenous ketones that he throws into
his food.
Have you tried those yet?
Know how nasty the rocket fuel stuff
that when they first came out with a
liquid.
It is,
it is jet fuel.
I mean,
it'll,
it'll make you a quiver.
I mean,
I think that stuff tastes worse than,
than Iowasca.
But uh,
the now the new stuff,
they make it with Stevia.
It's all natural flavors like orange,
Quito,
candidates.
It's awesome stuff.
You.
What's the,
what's the thought process between
behind eating exoticness ketones?
How does that work?
Well,
here's what I've noticed.
I'm,
if I'm in a ketogenic state and Keto
adapted and I'm producing my own
ketones,
I feel a huge bump from a product like,
like that sergeant in addition,
right?
Uh,
if I'm in a carbohydrate necessary,
you know,
energy system and I haven't been in
Ketosis for awhile and then I have like,
oh,
okay,
well I'm going to get low sleep tonight,
so I want ketones.
I might feel like a slight difference,
but it's not going to be nearly as
dramatic as if I'm already in Ketosis.
Really?
Yeah.
Which is odd to me.
I don't know the mechanism of how it
works or if my body just more in tuned
to use them when there's no
carbohydrates there,
but it's night and day.
I think the product is expensive,
like 75,
85 bucks for 15 servings probably we're
going so I wouldn't use it every day,
but I'd use it for like a big race.
A Tasha and I are doing a 50 K in Zion
coming up in April.
I'll be using them for that for sure.
You would do it the morning of the race
during the race,
like 15 minutes beforehand and then
every couple hours in for sure.
And now.
How long have you been doing a Ketogenic
Diet?
A man,
at least a year and a half.
I've been in and out.
Obviously I'm not going to.
There is no point where I'll never eat
carbs again.
Yeah,
they're phenomenal.
There's periods of times where I'll do
like a 12 week block,
strict Kurtosis or 16 weeks in a row.
Straight district toast.
What do you find when you do that?
Like what's the difference?
The biggest thing that I feel is a
cognitive boost,
it's night and day.
The sharpness I have mentally is a.
I mean,
that's,
that's really what keeps me coming back
to it is the mental clarity and focus.
Um,
and then that's really interesting to
lose a little bit of water weight
because glycogen holds water in the
muscles so you don't lose any strength,
but you'll lose some of that water
weight.
And uh,
I just feel more flexible.
So when I do yoga and things like that,
like I can get into postures I could
never get into when a carbs.
Like I can't get into Lotus when I'm,
when I'm eating carbs,
even if it's only five pounds difference
in my overall body weight,
I can get into ketosis.
Oh yeah.
What the fuck.
So what,
where is it binding in your knees and
your hips?
Like what's,
what's holding you back while you're
holding water in for every gram of
glycogen,
you hold four grams of water in the
muscle.
So.
So it makes sense if you are loading on
carbohydrates and things,
even if you're not carb loading,
but if your carb dependent,
your muscles are going to hold more
water than if they weren't.
Is there any benefit to that as far as
utilization of energy or ketones?
I mean this is all coming out of Steve
Finney and Jeff Volek,
they wrote the art and science of low
carbohydrate living in the art and
science of low carbohydrate performance
and mark sisson of references them.
They really broke down studies on
athletes in a ketogenic diet and things
like that and saw exactly what,
what kind of enhancements that are being
done.
And they kind of broke the mold of what
was done before when they ran tests,
you know,
gatorade was running tests and it was
coming up like,
hey,
if you do this,
you simply aren't going to be able to
outperform somebody who has
carbohydrates.
They weren't looking at somebody that
was keto adapted.
So it does take six to eight weeks to
make your body prefer fat.
Okay.
So what they were doing was just trying
it on people.
They put them in a state of Ketosis for
like a couple of weeks and then two
weeks exactly two weeks or six to eight
weeks,
six to eight weeks.
And other people will tell you the
longer the better.
So if you were like,
these guys that are winning the western
states,
100 is 100 mile race,
um,
they're,
they're in it for years.
You know,
you do pretty strict for a year and a
half and then you see some,
some significant jumps in fat oxidation
rates.
So how many,
how much can I break down in an hour
while I'm under stress?
That changes dramatically.
The longer you stay in it.
Now when you do that,
is it beneficial to put on some body fat
for a long race like that?
Because if you're in a ketogenic state,
your body can burn off that fat.
You would have.
They they've cry can't,
I can't read off numbers off the top of
my head,
but I mean when they talk about how
many,
how much calories you can hold from
glycogen stored in the liver and all the
carb loading you can do versus how much
fat you have on your body.
You could run for days.
That's why we confessed.
It's literally why.
That's another thing like to dispel a
bodybuilder myth on muscle.
If we lost muscle dramatically from
fasting,
then how do we chase down the heard
three,
four or five days into not having food
like,
right.
We for sure evolve to be able to do this
so we could go long periods of time and
have our explosiveness when we needed
it,
you know,
and they weren't jumping on treadmills
and doing stupid shit like we have to do
now,
but at the same time,
like it was important for human beings
to be able to have energy still in a
fasted state for that long.
And what you're talking about for people
who are unaware,
it's called persistence hunting and it's
one of the first methods of hunting that
ancient people used to do and still do
in parts of Africa where they'll run and
chase down.
Like if an animal like an antelope,
they run very fast for short periods of
time,
but they overheat,
they get,
they get hot and they get tired and they
can't run like we can.
We can run at a slower pace for way
longer.
We could run all day because we sweat,
they don't sweat.
So they overheat.
And so what ancient hunters would do is
just chase them literally until they
dropped and they would stab them.
There's some pretty fucking trippy
videos of guys doing that today in
Africa.
That sounds bad ass.
It's pretty crazy.
They just chase these animals down until
eventually they just give up and then
they stab them.
I can't imagine the runner's high have
chasing prey that long.
And,
and like your,
that's your food.
It's not like,
Oh hey,
let's spend five grand and go into
safari.
Like that's your food.
You know,
like that must give you the thrill
alive.
Yeah.
I'm gonna bring us back for my family.
This is not something you did while you
were fighting?
No.
Um,
you know,
in fighting at the way I like to word
this is a,
I used to play video games and love to
do shit and I'm not knocking video
games.
I'm in a video game coming up here.
It's going to be awesome.
What does the Mafia three by two k
games.
Awesome.
The guy who played like a hitman or some
shit.
I'm the dude.
The dude,
the dude.
It's a one player game that's like a
grand theft auto.
Oh,
but you don't beat up hookers after
banging them.
You do like more a revenge game trying
to come after these guys for killing my
family.
Oh.
And I get to do.
I mean the whole thing is motion
capture.
So if you guy farts,
it's me and a suit doing it real.
Anything he does,
it's me doing it.
Wow.
So,
um,
how long did you have to do that for?
We're still working on it.
It's coming out this summer.
It's been,
I've been doing that for since I retired
last year and a half.
It's crazy how intensive video games are
about people working behind it now.
Uh,
grand theft auto,
five grand theft auto five had.
This is,
this is the trailer
mafia three.
Let's see here.
Don't tell,
don't,
don't
graphics
videos.
How long has it.
So is this you here with the backpack
dismay the whole way.
I had to do all that shit at the end
here.
I kicked this guy into the creek.
Uh,
the face is different.
It's an actor named Alex from New York.
He's awesome.
So the facial scan and the voice
just fucking video.
The video is incredible.
Whoa.
Does it feel bizarre having some dude's
face on your body now?
Because I've met him and he's awesome.
If he was a Douche then I would look at
it totally different.
But I love the guy.
He's awesome.
That would suck.
The fucking video.
Graphics are insane.
This is really downplayed too,
just because it's the youtube,
like when you,
when I go in the studio and see what
they've done with it and you get to play
the game,
the end game is just,
it's,
they have whole teams that do the
environment,
whole teams that do buildings,
everything you can go into.
There's not a door in the game that you
can't walk into and have some type of
environment to play with.
Just like the hair and the,
the grass when they were in nom,
they're flying with the helicopters,
so they look at the fucking grass,
the shadows,
and this is incredible.
The facial recognition is the same stuff
that Robert Zemeckis was using in his
movies when they walk in.
We flew to La to do it.
It's pretty.
Yeah.
Soundtrack.
Well it's late sixties,
early seventies officers.
Some good music to choose from.
This is awesome,
man.
Wow.
Well we get fucking some nights gory
kills for people that are into that sort
of thing.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's amazing how like if you want to
talk about people that work hard,
nobody works like why don't say nobody,
but they work some insane fucking long
hours,
man.
Putting together a video game with some
really time intensive stuff.
It's.
Yeah,
and it's around the clock.
Yeah.
You see these guys when I go,
when I go to the MOCAP studio,
it's real laid back the same place.
They do like the web game and the
basketball game,
that kind of thing.
But when you go in and you see the guys
that write the code and actually make
the game,
the,
these,
you can tell like they're,
if they're on a deadline,
get you're having to fix bugs and do all
kinds of things and there's just a
grind.
Like they're definitely putting in
extreme hours.
Yeah,
it's horrific.
But what I was getting to before I
jumped off on the side there was in,
in fighting,
I always had.
I had,
uh,
an idea of what I could do with my time
and if I had a fight coming up and I'm
playing video games,
there's nothing like a deadline of this
guy's gonna try to knock me out in six
weeks,
five weeks,
four weeks,
three weeks,
every day you start to look at that day,
at the end of the day and say,
what did I do today to make myself
better?
How did I spend my time?
And if my pie chart had three hours of
entertaining myself,
when it could have been learning about
something else to help me,
like nutrition or different training
modalities,
that kind of thing.
I mean,
the choice was made.
I'll just overnight it was like,
okay,
I'm done playing video games.
I have a playstation three just
collecting dust.
I don't have a new jet.
Next generation I'll probably get one
just to play this game.
But um,
yeah,
that really instilled in me a love and a
thirst for knowledge.
And that's when I started reading about.
I've read more books in my fight career
than I ever did in college.
That's interesting ever.
I mean,
I have these camps where that's really
how I'd spend my time is just trying to
figure out how to better myself for the
flight.
When you were in a strange position too,
because you were a guy who came to
martial arts sort of late in life,
so you came into it late in life as a
great athlete who's learning all the
different aspects of mma,
all the different martial arts
techniques and then competing in the
highest level of the sport,
like pretty much right away.
Yeah,
that was pretty dumb.
It could have gotten a lot smarter,
but yeah,
it could have gotten a lot,
lot more intelligently planning a career
and things like that,
but really it just all happened by
storm.
You know?
I agree that that's not the way to do
it,
but some people can.
John Jones,
you know,
there's a few guys that.
Can.
I look at,
talk about Jon Jones or a guy like
Daniel cormier.
You look at the wrestling background.
It's not like they were doing something
totally different in martial arts the
whole time,
whether you want to call it that or not.
They're in martial arts their whole
lives and then now they can focus on,
I mean look at corn maze has striking
because he didn't have to focus on.
He didn't have to spend time dividing up
that pie chart into wrestling practice
and other things.
Right.
You know,
just a little bit.
We'll keep them sharp there,
but I can really learn these other
things and dive into them.
What's also,
when you are a master at one of those
things like sort of how Damien Maia is,
would you Jitsu such a master at it that
all those other things,
you know,
he,
he just has to be proficient enough so
he can get you in a position where he
could use his mastery.
Even look at Verdugo is striking is
really improved over the years because
he always had jujitsu moves back.
Exactly,
exactly.
And had it on such a high level than
anybody he gets to the ground with is
pretty fucked.
You're in a real bad spot,
but your,
your path was the path of the ultimate
fighter.
You know,
that TV show and like in not even
eating,
not just people that are on the TV show,
but people that do well in the smaller
circuit,
you know,
smaller shows and then,
they get a couple of fights under their
belt and they start looking good and
then they get the call,
you know,
hey,
we need a fight.
Someone needs to um,
fight this guy on,
you know,
three weeks notice you willing to do
this.
That's how a lot of guys getting into
the UFC fall outs.
You know,
someone from another organization looks
attractive.
They've got something going on,
like,
this guy's got potential.
But to,
to engineer a career correctly,
you would do it the swim,
the sort of the same way they did with
floyd mayweather in boxing or someone
along those lines.
You would take them slowly through the
amateur ranks,
develop their skills and then test them
a little bit more,
every fight a little bit more.
Give them some fights where they can
work on some things.
Give him a guy who was a brawler.
Give them a guy who's a box.
Everybody's feather fisted.
Give them a guy who you know,
who's he hits really hard,
but he fades after two or three rounds
and there's all these different sorts of
tests that you can give a boxer and know
when they're ready for those tests were
the whole time they're getting their
cages to or reading time in,
getting all that butterflies out.
They're spending more time in the pocket
and inside the old telephone poll booth
up with you.
They just fucking put your ass in a
catapult.
Launched you into the deepest part of
the ocean.
It was quick.
Yeah.
Was doubt.
That was never a plan though,
right?
It was like something that's Sorta came
along.
Well,
football ended at Asu and I was pretty
depressed.
I didn't know what I wanted to do.
I knew I didn't want to have it fucking
desk job.
And uh,
athletics were really my outlet in life,
you know,
I hadn't discovered psychedelics or
meditation or any of that stuff.
Sorry.
So inappropriate.
No worries.
I had turned it up just so I could hear
you.
So,
um,
but what led you to,
I started training in mixed martial arts
just because I was tired of being a rat
on the wheel,
you know,
treadmills and lifting weights wasn't
doing it for me and 26.
Wow.
No martial arts at all before that.
Uh,
I mean I wrestled in high school,
so high school wrestling background ball
for years,
uh,
three years in,
two years in junior high.
I was decent,
not great but um,
but yeah,
so we got into it and then uh,
as I was learning,
there was a local guy down in Arizona
and he ran it like a little sleazy
organization down there and he was like,
Hey,
you know,
you're big.
And he looked good and I know you played
football at Asu.
Why don't you get in there and fight for
me?
And I was like,
I don't know man.
I fought a lot growing up.
But it's different.
It's different when you are in the
moment and you want to destroy someone
versus some guy who was trained for you,
you've never met before.
It's like,
do it,
get your feet wet.
If you like it,
do it again.
If you don't like it,
never do it again,
but at least try one time.
Right.
It's like,
okay.
So my first fight,
it was a 29 second victory.
Second fight was the 19 second victory,
both knees to the stomach off of like
three months in Muay Thai training.
And then from there I was,
looked like you knock a guy out,
you know,
that is fucking,
there's no drug like that.
I mean,
you're just like,
just lit up on fire.
And then I started training and really
trying to get more serious about it,
but I fought a lot of fights quickly.
So there was no development in between.
I got to five.
No,
inside five months.
I'm six zero a sign with the king of the
cage after that.
And then,
uh,
yeah,
I was getting $100 a fight.
My first fight fights.
Wow.
And then,
uh,
I got a thousand dollars a fight and
king of the cage.
And,
uh,
after I took my first loss I was still
training out,
kind of doing my own thing in Arizona,
so before Bader and those guys had their
own gym and so cain was at ak and I'm
from the bay area.
I was born and raised there,
so it just made sense.
Like I knew came from college,
but I didn't,
we weren't pals or anything,
I just knew him when I was playing
football and he was wrestling.
I was like,
oh,
it has to.
Heavyweight wrestler I hear is bad dude.
And then when I heard he was at k
already and you already had cost check
Swick Fitch Thompson Aka was already
Aka,
you know,
and,
uh,
frank shamrock had already been there.
Bob Cook had an in with the UFC,
that kind of thing.
So it just made sense to move home and
start training their full time.
And that's what I did.
And within I think six months they got
me on the ultimate fighter season eight
and the rest is history.
Wow.
Do you ever think of it like,
man,
if I had to do it all again differently,
how I would do it slower,
I would,
would take my,
there's a million changes I could have
made to it,
but in the end
I'm,
I'm really happy with what fighting gave
me.
Fighting brought me.
It just,
I mean I can't say like,
oh,
I give this all,
all the credit here,
but that doorway opened up other
doorways and those doorways open up
other doorways to me and that really was
a catalyst for me having just deep peace
inside,
you know,
and all these things came from that one
little bead in fighting,
you know,
like wanting to do better for myself
because the guy was going to punch me
meant learning about meditation,
learning about breathwork,
learning about just getting more to
life,
you know?
And then,
oh okay,
hey,
the psychedelics can be a teacher as
well,
you know,
those kinds of things all kind of came
to me in,
in that same timeline.
So it was sort of like the,
not necessarily anxiety,
but the urgency of knowing that you had
to prepare for combat,
that you're constantly trying to better
yourself because the consequences of not
doing that are so grave that it sort of
like ignited this fuel for improvement
in you.
Yeah.
I was like,
what the fuck did I do today?
You know,
like you look back at the end of the
day,
like,
what did I do today?
Did I do anything to make me better than
I,
you know,
like it's one thing to be a lot of guys
are like,
hey,
it only went to the gym twice a train
hard.
I got a massage.
That was my recovery.
I'm good,
I'm good with watching TV and just
vegging out and doing whatever.
And that's fine if you're.
I mean when you're beat sometimes you
just need to entertain yourself and
relax and that's fine too.
But you know that that just fueled
reading.
I'm really became like where I'm going
to read and in meditation,
but meditation,
I was like a lot of people.
I didn't get it for a very long time.
I just kind of forced myself to do it
and over time we've got a little easier,
but it wasn't until Iowaska that I
really understood meditation and now
with Wim Hoff,
I mean he's just added a whole nother
layer to meditation for me that I didn't
have before.
Same thing with my wife.
I mean the Wim Hof breathing techniques
are just.
They're phenomenal.
Yeah.
He's incredible.
I can't say enough good stuff about that
guy.
He's a fascinating character to.
You know,
what he's been able to do.
It was like the swimming underwater on
the blocks of ice,
the in the frozen ocean.
One hundred yards.
We're supposed to swim 50 and he missed
the whole and he doubled his distance
and then frozen retinas fucking g
couldn't see because eyeballs froze like
what?
God dammit.
He's incredible.
He's a very unusual human,
but a lot of people use that method.
Now,
that method of breathing,
I use it before go on stage.
I take these big crazy wim hoff breaths
before I go onstage.
There's something to in letting go.
Yeah.
The way in let her go.
He's.
He's quite a character.
Matt and he's quite a quite an
inspirational guy too.
There's a lot of people that have really
gravitated towards him.
His story was amazing and I've heard him
on Ferris.
I heard them on up in greenfields
podcast when you've had them on and you
correct beers.
He opened up,
you know what I'm saying?
Like you could tell he got comfortable.
You could get more from him than the
vice docket and I love vice,
but I thought the vice documentary,
it was shit 40 minutes.
This guy is fixing his fucking hair and
I can't tell if people are following
because he's so charismatic or not like
no dude.
That face,
that feeling is believing,
right?
The second you feel that charge and your
hands three,
four or five rounds deep,
you know,
like he's not full of shit.
Like you're feeling cheat,
you're feeling energy,
you're feeling what you can label it
whatever you want,
but I mean you do.
You feel good inside.
That's undeniable.
Well,
inspiration is,
is a type of fuel,
right?
I mean when you get inspired,
you fire up.
You literally can feel yourself getting,
getting pumped.
Right?
Well,
what is that?
If you hear a great song,
were you working out and you're like,
and you just get fucking pumped.
That's a real thing.
Whatever that is,
like whatever that is,
whatever the feeling that you get that
comes along with inspiration,
like whether it's a great movie or a
great song or something that just really
gets you.
That energy is real.
You know Israel,
where the person's coming from.
Well that's thousands of years.
People have discussed it and know some
people,
oh,
that's woo shit,
or what are you going to tell me what my
fucking aura looks like?
I can't see your fucking whore of,
but I do believe we had this energy
field and fact there's,
there's books and there's science that
backness.
Now I'm Valerie Hunt wrote a infinite
mind.
She was a professor at Ucla and they
actually have a place in Ucla where they
can conduct studies on the human energy
field and they've mapped this out by
changing things.
The electromagnetism they can make
people have emotional breakdowns,
lose complete loss of motor control like
they have just all of a sudden they have
to sit.
That can't even stand the kid keep
themselves up,
but how are they doing it?
Like with like they're manipulating
through ion?
No,
no,
no.
That's like a metal to get a giant metal
room,
some type of special room that they have
them go in and uh,
they just change this thing on a dial
and the field influences your human
energy field.
Whoa.
And it's fucking verified that did this
a while ago too.
That's as crazy as it's like they've
known about this seventies,
eighties for sure.
This is an incredible radiolab podcast
where,
um,
uh,
they,
they put electrodes on this woman,
they center through this sniper training
video game thing that they do where you
have like a rifle and a,
there's a video game in front of you and
presented with all these different
scenarios,
like a hostage takeover.
This terrorist show up.
They start shooting at you and you tried
to shoot the terrorist under duress,
you know,
you're stressed out.
And so they take her through this thing.
She does terrible.
Just her.
Everything's off,
just panicky everything.
And then they do it when they attach
these electrodes tour and stimulate with
electricity.
Parts of her head just on the outside,
like transdermally.
I think it's where they doing electrical
stimulation.
Certain frequencies when they're trying
to manipulate frequency or it was just
trying to work like on frontal lobe or
things like that.
I don't know.
I don't know the exact science behind
it,
but she then did it and went like 10 for
10,
like killed everybody.
Like it was insane.
Like her accuracy went through the roof.
Now the kids doing this shit where they
try to make their own at a battery
packs.
Like,
Hey,
this is all new science and has been
doing this for decades.
We don't know what the ramifications
are.
That was the Radiolab podcast sort of
focused on some of those people.
Like,
oh well I went deaf for a couple of
days.
Like fuck you do in your head man,
because they're just taking like nine
volt batteries and like taping wires to
their skull and juicing themselves.
No fucking clue what they're doing.
If there's something going on and they,
the researchers that are working on it,
I think that they can accentuate
learning.
They can accentuate flow states where
you get into some sort of a zen moment
guaranteed if you're familiar with
binaural beats,
right?
Yes.
So a binder that's something that for in
the 19 fifties,
they wanted to see what a sound sound
wave therapy could do and things like
that.
And basically,
um,
so you would wear headphones or earbuds
and the basic concept,
the premise would be I can play
something at eight Hertz through your
left and 12 hertz through your right.
And your brain will match them in the
middle at 10 hertz.
10 Hertz is the
frequency of Alpha waves.
So our brain produces a wide variety of
different waves from zero point five
delta when you're in deep sleep all the
way up to Beta state,
which we're in right now,
drinking coffee and thinking.
In between that you have an Alpha state
which is closer to the earth's
residents,
the earth's magnetic field where that's
like a meditative state.
So you could have a flow state there.
And Rob Marcus has spoken about this,
um,
that is the flow state range between
like seven point eight to 11,
somewhere in there.
Then below that deep meditation,
state of state,
pre sleep,
and then delta and,
and there's other other things in there,
but basically through a binaural beats
you put on these headphones,
you can listen to whatever,
uh,
the ocean or rain or any of these things
and you would have these different
frequencies playing through your years
in,
in that you basically trick your brain
into producing these brainwaves.
And within minutes you feel like,
oh,
I just took a really nice nap.
Like I feel good,
I feel refreshed,
that kind of thing.
Wow.
That would probably be great if you were
in like a pool tournament or something
like that.
Like something where you want us to get
into zones and get in the zone.
Like I would think like archery or darts
or something where you just like,
or,
or three pointers,
you know,
shooting three pointers.
We just get into that field [inaudible],
whatever that is,
whatever that flow state is.
Oh,
you're thoughtless.
Basically,
you know,
when you're in the Beta state that's,
you were thinking,
your mind is racing.
That I was in the Beta state two nights
ago when I,
when I had three hours of sleep thinking
of all these possible possible rabbit
holes,
we'd go down to conversation wise.
Yeah.
That's,
uh,
that,
that state of the lack of sleep state
is,
uh,
my shittiest thinking state.
I come up with my worst thoughts when
I'm exhausted or can't turn the mind
off.
A lot of people have that issue.
Yeah.
Well the,
um,
there's also like some silly creative
ideas though that come up when you're
exhausted.
Like sometimes when I'm exhausted I'll
say the most ridiculous shit and it'll
turn out to be funny.
Like I have to write it down.
Like where I'm like,
you know,
the writers on news radio,
the Sitcom I was back in the day,
they used to stay up late on purpose.
They wouldn't start writing until two or
three in the morning and they would get
themselves into like an exhausted stupor
and then they would start writing
because all the running would be like
really hilariously silly because they
were just fucking falling asleep.
They were just there just out of it.
Like there's a state that you get that a
lot of writers to try to trick
themselves into just by like getting
exhausted.
Yeah.
It makes sense.
So when you were,
when you're fighting,
like what was the first sort of
improvement path that you started upon
diet nutrition right off the bat.
That was the one where I was like,
Hey,
this is something I can control.
It'll help me just recovery,
you know,
how do I recover faster?
How do I flush metabolic waste?
Um,
yeah,
there really was it.
I mean,
I've always been into supplements.
I read the muscle mag since I was a
little kid.
That kind of thing.
And uh,
certain
stuff works,
a lot of stuff doesn't.
But really,
um,
what you put in your body has a huge
impact.
I mean,
anybody who's ever cleaned up their diet
and felt differently from it.
When you're listening to red band
talking about the wage loss and how he
has the energy now,
it just feels happy at it.
Like,
right.
Well that's in rainmaker also.
He talks about 80 percent of our
serotonin is made in our guts bacteria.
Eighty percent of our feel good hormone
is made in our guts by bacteria.
And that's great.
What are you saying?
Yeah.
How do you think food does it impact
that?
We know every cell of our body is made
from what we put in.
So a lot of people don't think,
oh,
he eat this doughnut and it'll just.
My body will change it into what it
needs to be changed into bullshit.
No.
And on top of that,
you influence the microbiome,
but what you put in your body,
if you putting good stuff,
it's easy to see like,
yeah,
of course you feel better.
Yeah.
We like to think of ourselves as
independent from our food,
but were actually made out of our food.
That's completely.
I was uh,
I had salmon the other night at a
restaurant and um,
I said to my friend,
I said to Tony,
Tony Hinchcliffe,
I was like,
I don't think this is wild salmon.
And he said,
why?
I said,
because it's too light.
It's too light colored.
I don't,
you know,
they said it's a wild line caught
salmon.
And I'm like not really buying it.
And uh,
I said,
you know,
when you see wild salmon,
it's more of a dark orange.
And he said,
well,
why is that?
I said,
well,
it's actually because of what they eat.
It's come on bugs like certain bugs that
they eat or shrimp.
What the fuck is it shrimper bugs find
on West Santa Ana.
Read,
ask,
ask.
US has sustained,
and I know I'm butchering this asks us
strengthen.
It's like a and t h I n s sold in
supplements.
Sockeye Salmon,
a salmon flush due to their diet.
Sam,
again,
99 percent or more of their body mass
and the ocean,
the foods they eat,
but blah,
blah,
blah.
I'm the food they eat in the ocean is
high and carotenoids the same pigment
that gives carrots color.
These pigments are stored in their
flesh.
A salmon approaches their spawning
grounds begin to absorb the scales.
Huh?
They begin to absorb their scales.
A weird.
They,
um,
they get mushy.
Have you ever caught a caught a salmon
when it's dying?
Banners.
We went into,
I had a bachelor party.
My buddy goes up every year to Alaska,
so we went fishing off the Kenai river,
but we were,
we just fit it in before his wedding,
so we were about a month or two late to
the party.
It was a feast for Seagulls,
like all these old timers that spawned
and they're like swimming along,
like just fucking,
just full layers of skin and scale is
just floating off of them ready to die.
Yeah.
They become mushy.
Their flesh is like difficult to eat
too.
It's like disgusting.
Yeah,
it's nasty.
Like you could eat it if you have to,
if you want to stay alive,
but they're literally breaking down and
had a little sashimi and that was a.
That was a mistake for sure.
You should never eat salmon Sashimi.
Really?
Yeah.
It's not a smart move because they have
parasites,
ocean fish or much better in regards to
uh,
being.
So if you caught the salmon in the
ocean,
you're cool to do it.
Then he even then,
because they go there,
they go back and forth.
I think is something about fresh water
fish are much more susceptible to,
um,
southern nasty shit we put in there
probably.
Yeah.
I don't even know if it's nasty shit we
put in there.
I think that's just nature.
I think fish in the ocean naturally are
of a higher,
less likely hood of a contracting.
Any sort of parasites or you have a
higher likelihood of getting it from.
I'm a freshwater fish.
Like you should never eat like large
mouth bass.
Like Sashimi.
You shouldn't eat that.
I don't think.
I really don't think I'm talking out of
my ass here.
I'm pretty sure of.
I've read that you're not supposed to
eat salmon Sushi,
but people do.
Yeah.
People do and it doesn't.
But anyway,
point being this fish was really kind of
Pale and then we were talking about like
how weird it is that your food actually
changes the color of your skin.
And we were talking about black bears
that eat blackberries and blueberries,
like if you eat,
um,
they,
like certain hunters will go after bears
that are in the fall because the fall
bears the gorge on blueberries and their
flesh is just supposed to be
unbelievably delicious.
Like some of the best tasting meat you
can get because they're their flesh.
And then their fat itself is like a
purple color from all the blueberries.
Like it changes their actual physical
flesh and it makes it absorb.
It just makes you think about all these
people that are eating McDonald's
twinkies and shit.
Like what is their flesh?
It's just high fructose corn Syrup and
Trans Fats.
Just dog shit.
Just pumping through your testimony in
college.
Just any calories that can get ahold of
just brutal.
Well,
you know,
ultimately that stuff breaks down the
protein and water and all the various
aspects of it.
But if that's all you eat,
no wonder why so many people are
depressed.
If you look at the modern American Diet,
you look at the modern American diet,
the sedentary lifestyle,
and then you look at the fact that
people feel like shit.
And what is depression?
Well,
there's all sorts of different kinds of
depression.
There's some depression that's
absolutely caused by a chemical
imbalance.
Your brain's sick.
You know,
just like your liver can get sick and
your lungs can get sick,
your brain can get sick,
but there's a whole lot of depression
that I guarantee has to do with people
with sedentary lifestyle,
Shitty Diet,
and just no,
no real pushing of the body where your
body never gets to flush it out.
Never gets to blow those hormones up.
Never gets to get that blood pumping
out.
Argue.
The brain gets sick because you let it
get.
That way.
You stop moving and stop putting good
things in your body.
And then you have this downward spiral
that just snowballs into deep depression
that know your buddy coming over and
it's going to cheer you up.
Whatever it is,
you're not going to snap yourself out of
that just overnight and you're
definitely not going to get it from
popping a pill.
I mean,
you gotta get off your ass and move and
start getting back out in nature.
Yeah.
To the pill thing is a weird one because
I know for some people it's been very
beneficial.
I know people that were like severely
depressed,
they got an antidepressants and they
eventually wean themselves off,
but they got happy first.
So it's like,
what?
Did they need the pills?
No,
but the pills did help them and I
wonder.
I don't,
I'm not going to indicate that at all,
but I wonder what lifestyle choices did
they make during that process as they
started feeling better?
Like,
oh,
I feel a little bit better.
Sure,
let's go for a hike.
Whatever it is.
Like what did they do in addition to
that?
Right.
That helped them.
So they don't have the pills now,
right,
because they're off the pills now.
So how do you get to that point where
you can be like a,
I don't need this anymore.
You know what,
dudes that I know,
one of them,
he got married,
fell in love,
started his own business,
his business became very successful,
started doing really well in life,
start feeling better about himself,
and then it all sort of fell together
and then he said,
you know what,
I'm going to get off these fucking
pills,
and he slowly weaned himself off and
he's still happy and the other one got
successful and got more confident and
then realize that the pills were
probably like dulling his senses and
some sort of way and then slowly weaned
himself off,
but he hasn't really got into a
exercise.
The other thing he did was he got off
Propecia,
that propecia shit that dudes do to keep
their hair that took that and college
stuff killed my Dick.
Like a CHT blocker.
Right?
Yeah.
Dht makes you a man,
makes you bald,
makes you have body hair.
Don't want to get rid of that
testosterone to get rid of that.
Well,
it can depress people.
It can cause severe depression.
Some people,
you know,
it didn't in me,
but it definitely killed my deck,
like a gun.
That would make me depressed just right
then.
That's depressing.
It doesn't totally kill it,
but it's definitely.
What beats the fuck out of it.
Come on.
What are you doing?
Why are you doing this to me?
Yeah.
Well they say that you know,
there's a,
there's a balance that your hormones
achieve and anytime you fuck with that
balance with something like propecia
that you know that blocks
dihydrotestosterone,
your body's like,
all right,
well what the hell is going on here?
Why is this block like,
what?
Wha Wha wha,
wha.
What is our issue here?
And it can cause a cascade of issues
like anytime you'd like to,
to treat the body as anything other than
a holistic approach.
If you have a holistic approach,
you look at this guy's depressed.
Okay,
well let's look at his diet.
No,
no,
no.
We need to get them on a pill.
Well that doesn't make any sense.
You need to look at the whole thing.
Like what's his diet like?
How often does he sleep?
What is he?
Does he drink a lot of water?
Does he have something to get over?
It's something that was fucking his wife
die.
His Dad's clean.
His Shit.
You know what's going on there.
There's sometimes you just have to
overcome.
You just have to overcome a periods of
life that just suck.
That's,
that's real too.
You know what I,
I mean,
people want to
fix for that.
Uh,
give me a bill.
I got to get past the stage of life.
Only you're going to sleep through it.
That's everything though with the,
with the Western medicine.
It's just that I'm broken.
Fix Me.
Let me go.
You're the professional and fixed my
knee.
My hip pain medicine is the shit though.
If you break your arm,
they fixed my shoulder when I was a dumb
ass and had a torn labrum.
I love it for that.
But what would happen to your shoulder
would you do that?
Was overtraining and uh,
decided to try to Max out on barbell
snatch and missed it with it.
Didn't feel anything there.
Then I waited a minute and reattempted
the same weight and then I felt like it
just felt like no strength at all.
So it was a full slap tear came to the
same thing it takes for a.
you're right,
we've just been talking to people that
have shoulder surgery.
I think I thought I had this dumb ass
idea in my head like,
oh,
you know,
I'll be able to run still.
And I'm like,
no,
you can't do any of that.
I couldn't even walk.
I had to be very careful with my arm in
a sling for at least the first six
weeks.
Then at six months I could start rehab.
It took me a whole year.
We really did.
And really I give a ton of credit to
Kelly,
start a for getting full range of motion
back.
The becoming a supple leopard guy and
like I had for a long period of time
thought like this is as far as my arm's
going to go.
Not quite that.
Not Quite Hail Hitler,
but you know,
like I had no full range of motion.
I can get my bicep.
Yeah.
Couldn't get my bicep to my ear and I
knew it was short in certain positions.
Like if you get in grappling,
Jujitsu,
wrestling,
things like that guy sprawls while
you're holding a single leg that's nine,
that three inches makes all the
difference in the world.
Like from feeling like,
Hey,
this guy's putting pressure on me,
I should change positions or my arm's
going to snap.
Right?
That's the difference.
If you defending,
looked a head and arm choke on the right
side and someone tries to straighten
your arm out,
what does that like when he presses up
against your head?
Everything's fine now.
But initially it was a nightmare.
Yeah.
Like just,
I couldn't get biceps to ear while I'm
talking to you.
So for sure if someone's trying to do
that to me,
then it's going to feel like something's
gonna tear
six months before you can start doing
rehab.
And that was a process that was,
you know,
just nasty.
So,
um,
I know now listen to my body,
don't push the envelope,
nothing.
You know?
And then we slap tear.
What does that mean?
It's an acronym.
It's the placement of the.
What is it?
The placement of will.
The labor room is like the,
it holds this ball in place.
Right.
So slap is the position of it.
It's on the front side.
I've,
if I remember correctly,
it was a few years ago,
but um,
yeah,
it's all placement.
All arthroscopic go in there and sew it
back up.
Is that what they did?
Yeah.
I have very,
very minimal scarring there.
But yeah,
it's basically what it is.
They just go in,
they do everything through the,
through the vision of the,
the little cameras and it's easy.
It's easy fix for them.
And it had a great guy.
He's worked on tons of NFL guys I got
and I'm grateful that I have full
recovery,
but really it's,
it's a nasty deal
to have to go through.
Yeah.
Tait Fletcher just went through
something like this weekend.
He went through something.
He just texted me about a.
hold on one second.
It,
uh,
it's something called.
This is really interesting shit,
man.
It's okay.
It's called highland highland x
injections there.
Site injections,
whether impediments to movement and um,
anything they have with sliding tissue.
Oh,
there it is.
Highland X.
and uh,
he was saying that,
uh,
it's an enzyme and that they're,
they're testing on people that have
joint issues and somehow or another it's
supposed to mitigate the issues of
mobility in a joint problems.
I think I need to get my dad in that he
gave.
He can't open his arms as far as his
arms go.
How come you could arm bar?
I'm like,
the east got like calcium deposits and
shit in his elbows.
He's had surgery on both of them to him.
From what?
Uh,
you know,
he's,
he's eating cleaner now,
but for years he ate whatever the hell
he wanted and he still did.
I mean he got his black belt a year ago.
So he does.
He's on the mat all the time.
He does a lot of Jujitsu.
I'm how old you done?
Sixty four.
That's amazing.
Gets his black belt at 63.
What a stud.
He started at 56 dud.
He was a fat loser with a super,
super stressed job,
you know,
sales.
And then when I started fighting,
he got into Jujitsu.
He did full contact karate,
boxing,
wrestling.
So he understood,
striking,
understood.
Wrestling,
but the second hit the mat,
he was like,
I don't know what the fuck these guys
are doing,
like have to learn.
And uh,
once he started immediately became
addicted.
Like anybody who does Jujitsu,
you know,
the feeling you get when you first start
and he lost 50 pounds without even
changing his diet in the first six
months.
So it was a,
it's been a life changer for them for
sure.
That's fucking great.
I love hearing that.
Like Anthony Bourdain keeps saying he'll
never get his black belt bullshit.
That guy will get his black belt.
He started when he was,
I think 57 and he's got his blue belt
now at 58.
He'll get it for sure.
He'll get it.
He's a maniac.
He takes one private and one full class.
One,
one regular class a day everyday,
everyday,
everyday cheese.
Why not if you've got cheese?
Yeah,
he's got the cheese and he's also got
the obsession.
And you know,
it's funny,
I talked to Bj Penn about this.
Bj Penn was hilarious about this.
He was talking to this guy and the guy
was like,
you know,
uh,
he told you no,
because Bj famously got his black belt
in three years and one day,
one day,
all three years in,
and this guy had gotten his black belt
somewhere,
I think around four years.
And a Bj was like,
well,
he goes,
man.
He goes,
you,
you must be really talented.
And he goes,
no,
man.
He goes,
I'm obsessed.
I'm addicted.
Like you,
And bj started laughing.
He goes,
I realized,
yeah,
I was addicted.
I was addicted to like,
you can get
addicted to good things too.
Oh yeah,
no question.
I mean,
that's,
that,
that is runners high.
That's why people would sign up for a
race that's,
wait,
it's not healthy for you to run that
far,
but it feels good training and preparing
and getting your body ready for that.
And that keeps you coming back for more.
Yeah.
Like 100 mile runs.
Those are fucking terrible.
Destroy you.
They've got to be bad you.
They've done blood work on people even
not just after a marathon,
which is ridiculous in its own right,
but they would see like borderline
kidney failure,
like your kidneys can barely keep up
with removing metabolic waste.
Yeah.
You don't look after those things and
your piss looks like Coca Cola.
Well,
I'm out.
No.
Oh,
never want to get to the point where I p
looks like coke.
That's fucking terrible man.
But people like they also get addicted
to pushing themselves.
That's a big one.
You know,
like my friend Cameron Hanes,
he's a bow hunter,
but he's also does ultra marathons.
A lot of merit.
He started getting in shape just so he
could get up the mountains easier.
Like cars in bowhunting.
There's two things that come into play.
One,
you have to be fit in order to get up
the mountains because all that hiking,
it's exhausting,
especially at high altitude and two,
you have to be strong to be able to pack
out.
Like you carry an animal,
you kill it and you have to get it down
in the mountains.
A lot of work.
So those two things led him down this
road of starting to do marathons and
lifting a lot of weights and doing all
these different things.
But now he's doing ultra marathons.
He's doing something called the big foot
challenge.
It's 200 miles.
So I go 100 miles a day and the next day
another hundred miles like
damn,
I wonder what the cutoff is for that
because sometimes they're right around
like 22 hours.
Just what do you do?
You take an hour nap and then go right
back to running.
I don't even know if you sleep.
I mean you probably in so much agony
after 24 hours of running 200 miles.
That's so stupid.
100 wasn't enough guys.
It's weed out the policies here and they
get 200 some lady in my neighborhood did
it.
She.
She did 200 fucking miles.
She did a mile.
One hundred miles one day.
One hundred miles the next day.
Bitch is crazy.
Yeah.
I say bitch with all due respect
and admiration.
Damn.
Yeah.
I don't.
I don't mean leslie anything wrong with
her.
She's just tough as shit.
But they get addicted to like pushing
them.
Sounds like there's a thing that comes
to some people when they get involved in
these heavy endurance races were part of
the.
The addiction is one more hour,
five more miles,
10 more miles.
Just push your kid into a.
You do get into a flow state and it does
you.
The longer you go,
the better it feels.
I mean obviously you can deal with
ticketek injuries and things like that
or whatever you got to deal with in the
race.
But at a certain point in time the
mental chatter quiets down and you just
find your rhythm and you find your
breathing and that's,
that can be meditative completely.
And the longer it goes,
the better for people like that.
Once you're in that state,
you know,
I mean,
I've,
I've felt that in half marathons on the
last six miles and finish stronger in
the end than I did in the first half.
You know?
And I'm sure runners be like,
oh yeah,
of course we ran more.
You'd know that dummy for that,
that I get that.
So that's why we sign up for this 50 k
coming up just for the fact like,
all right,
Kelly started a 50 k at 230 pounds.
It can be done.
Right?
You know,
and I'm not saying I'm going to make a
regular habit of this,
I don't think it's healthy by any means,
but I do want to do it.
A 50 is like a mile time,
right?
A marathon is what?
It's a little bit longer to think.
I think a marathon is 26 point two miles
and a 50 k's run around 33.
Oh,
okay.
That makes sense to point.
Jamie would know the powers of,
of Google,
the powers of Google 31 miles.
Jamie's a runner too.
So,
um,
that's um,
so is that what fuels your competitive
desires now?
I like doing different things,
you know,
like working out with Jesse burdick.
He's the guy who does power,
he's a beast.
Uh,
you know,
so training once a week I'll go up and
train with him and Dublin at CSA and we
do some heavy,
heavy lower body.
It could be anything.
So we'll squat heavy.
One day we'll do a heavy sumo deadlift,
heavy conventional to whatever,
you know,
like there's just a,
it's good to train with guys that are
way better than you at whatever their
respective thing is,
you know,
and I feel like I have,
I can go in there and learn from him and
the guys that got working out there.
That doesn't mean a lot of good and I
love lifting who doesn't want to be
stronger.
Like if you,
once you get a taste for that,
that is an addictive thing and I love
lifting heavy weight because I feel
better throughout the week.
You know?
I just feel better as a person doing
that.
When I'm in shape,
I feel better being in shape.
So going for longer distance runs and
having something,
you know,
if there's light at the end of the
tunnel,
like April ninth,
I'm running the 50 k.
That makes it easy for me to come home
when I'm tired and say I got to get at
least three miles in today.
That kind of thing.
You know,
like I know this event's coming up so
I'm going to put in some roadwork today
and it doesn't fuck with your shoulder
at all.
This heavy lifting the shoulders.
A hundred percent know why and I give
full.
I can't.
I mean it sound like I'm blowing the
guy,
but Kelly start really.
I have everything to thank from that
guy.
What did you do that he will have his
banded mobility and you can look them on
a mobilitywod.com.
He posted 500 videos on youtube.
He's got a shoulder one that's I think
five minutes long and that long,
but he shows eight different stretches
for the shoulder using one of those
rogue bands.
Right?
And you spent two minutes in a stretch
minimum.
So there's 20,
32nd hold shit is out the window.
He talks about Fascia in order to
release it really has to be,
have some time under tension and you
know,
you distract things.
So I couldn't.
I wouldn't get the same experience if I
put my hand on a wall and try to stretch
my chest.
Right?
But if I can pull in this band,
it distracts the impingement in my
shoulder and now the Fascia,
the palm of my hand,
and my thumb will go all the way to my
ear lobe and open up a.
So I'll feel everything the same way a
foam roller can,
can relax my it band right now.
I can get that for my shoulder and all
these different positions.
And that's what gives me my mobility
back.
So the basic idea is that hey,
I can be able to get in this position
cold,
right?
That's what I wrote.
He name is booked at supple Leopard
Leopard's.
You don't see them getting up and having
to do a five minute warmup guys and
catch up with you in a second.
You know,
they're not,
you know,
I do downward dog upward dog and then
boom,
they're going right.
So I have that ability,
my shoulder now because of putting in
that work over time.
Well that's what a lot of fighters are
realizing now.
The importance of softness and
flexibility and,
and just to be pliable and you have to
be mobile.
Yeah,
you have to be mobile.
And to be rigid and stiff,
it impedes movement,
like I see it a lot from people when
they're trying to kick.
When I see guys kicking and I see like
stiffness and like sort of a general
lack of fluidity and the way they move,
I can tell immediately I'm like,
this guy's just not flexible enough to
throw on these kicks.
And there's all this resistance from
their supporting leg.
There's resistance from the kicking leg
and then there's resistance from their
torso.
You could see it all as they start
throwing kicks and then the kick will
come up instead of go across the hip,
won't be high enough.
That won't be as much a forward movement
with the hip.
Definitely could be mental too though.
You know,
I always looking back,
honestly on my career,
I fought stiff,
stiff as fuck,
right?
Like really stiff.
I never sparred.
I never fought the way I sparred.
Rather look at Luke rockhold and I'm
like,
that guy fights the way he spars.
Like he doesn't give a fuck what's
coming at him.
He kicks beautiful.
And with everything is thrown is with
power,
right?
Yeah.
So he mentally got to that point where
he was just like,
I know I'm going to destroy you and I'm
not worried about what you.
How much difference was there with you
with how you performed in the gym versus
how much you,
how you performed inside the octagon?
The,
I think it was a fairly big difference.
Like a 30 percent difference.
Twenty percent difference.
I don't know how,
if I could put a number on it,
I just felt like,
you know,
I mean there's.
Hmm.
I mean it's hard to gauge with a guy
like cain.
Cain destroyed everyone,
you know,
it'd be like,
Oh,
you know,
there's this time I sparred Kane and I
got them like,
no,
you can't whoop my ass every time we
spark.
But there was a point in time where I
did well with Daniel.
Cormier are times where I did well with
Luke rockhold times where I did well
with Mike Kyle and,
and pull them Otello and you know,
even in my best fights in the UFC,
like with Ricardo Ramiro,
think those.
The only time I got to get interviewed
by you afterwards,
it took me like a.
The only reason the fight turned out
that way and I was able to get into the
zone was because I was so sick the night
before.
I fought like two.
Oh eight.
Like I had fucking sweat the bed.
I was rolling around in my sweat,
just soaked a bed.
This worst fever I've ever had and in
the fight I'm walking out and I was
guest.
After two minutes of warming up,
I stopped warming up in the in the
locker room completely gassed and I
thought like,
I'm fucked if this thing goes longer
than men and I'm done.
And then I realized right then Brian,
when they shut the cage door,
I have to fight.
There's nothing I can do here but fight
and right when I made that realization,
that put me in the zone because there
was no thought.
That's why the fight is 23 seconds.
Whatever it was.
It felt like it was in slow motion and I
could never get back to that point
because they didn't have
the technical skills mentally to do it,
or there's the knowhow of how I got
there.
You know,
like I knew I could look back in
hindsight and say,
yeah,
that's,
this was the catalyst.
I had my back against the wall and I
just completely let go.
I know from Iowasca ceremonies and
things like that,
like there's a big lesson in letting go
and surrendering to the process is like
don't fight it.
Just fucking go with uh,
but those things didn't transfer the way
I had hoped.
You know,
I talked about that before my last
fight.
I hoped that the lessons I learned from
Iowasca of surrender would transfer and
I would have this like,
I don't give a fuck mentality.
We're going to do this.
And looking back on that fire,
I didn't.
I was still nervous to show,
even though looking at photos online and
you know,
pat's going to punch me.
I wasn't afraid of getting punched.
No offense to pet cummins.
I wasn't afraid of getting punched by
him.
Not after glover and in MANITOWOC and
I'm still like,
I'm squeezing the low fat,
you know,
right as he's about to hit me.
Like I'm stiff,
rigid tents.
So there wasn't a transfer there of,
of skills from the beauty of Iowasca
because it wasn't,
you didn't know enough time to process
it or you needed more of those
experiences or there was a really,
there's a number,
you know,
there's a large,
large,
there's a.
everything kind of goes together with
that.
I think,
um,
really,
you know,
spending time developing yourself
longer,
right?
Having a,
there's no eight week camp where I'm
going to be as good a wrestler is that
guy,
period.
It doesn't matter who I'm working with.
Um,
that said,
obviously you can build a game plan and
work on take down a fence and look it
over in.
St Louis did great against him.
He was an excellent fight.
So I could,
you know,
like in hindsight maybe it could have
done it like that,
you know,
maybe I could have had better footwork
and done these things and worked on
whatever.
I don't know.
I don't really put too much thought into
how I could've done that better now
because I have really accepted the fact
that I'm done doing that.
You know,
like the more I would put thought into
how I could've done it better,
the more it makes me want to do it.
Right.
Does that make sense?
What was the big deciding factor to make
you want to retire?
It really,
really was a,
a number of things.
But
you know,
I had a second job the whole time I was
in the UFC.
Even with the fight,
the fight of the nights at to fight of
the nights.
I got to train full time for maybe six
months and then the first loss I had to
go right back to work.
So bouncing at the titty bar,
bartending,
managing that kind of stuff.
And um,
you need sleep for recovery.
And I had that just felt that window of
I can sleep and train full time and know
what it's like to have full recovery now
it's yanked back away from me.
Why was it yanked back away?
Because you,
when you lost,
who made less money?
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
And,
and well,
with the fracture to like even take for
example,
when I had a uh,
one of those fights,
I got fight of the night with Maldonado.
That was my only fight that year.
So I got an extra 40 grand.
That's when I was getting 10 and 10.
That's 60 grand,
10 percent coaches,
10 percent of management pay the irs.
That's not a lot spread over the year
and it's less than a teacher.
So I needed to work,
you know,
and then that's Kinda how it goes.
If you have you,
if you,
if you get hurt in a fight and you only
fight that once that year,
that could be the,
the difference.
Yeah.
It's ridiculous.
When you think about how much risk
versus reward there is in the sport of
fighting,
like at the very high levels.
Like when you're conor mcgregor or Ronda
Rousey,
yeah,
you're going to make millions of
dollars.
But on the way up to that like,
fuck,
can you break through,
you know,
that's really what it comes down to.
And at the same time I was,
you know,
becoming familiar with Iowasca was
having a ceremonies where a lot of shit
was getting uncovered.
And I don't mean like,
Oh,
I've worked through all this baggage and
all.
No,
there was,
there was V,
I had many,
many great visions and each ceremony has
its own.
It's its own thing.
It's completely unique from another same
thing with dmt that it's its own fucking
thing.
And it helped me grow as a person.
I can't say which ceremony made me not
have that spark.
But over time that spark went away.
The spark to want to destroy another
person slowly left me.
And it doesn't matter what a fighter
tells you on a flight because of this,
a fight,
because of that,
they all inside them want to destroy
another person.
Deep down inside they want to destroy
something.
Well,
that's what victory is.
Yeah,
you have to want to.
That victory is you submit someone or UK
on them.
I mean that's the ultimate victory.
You stopped them and that's really
difficult to do.
So the,
the challenge is extremely high.
And then the reward,
the endorphins,
the rush,
the feeling of accomplishment,
all those things.
But at the end of the day,
I think probably what Iowasca and what
dmt would show you is that,
uh,
you know,
you're causing damage.
It's just this destructive thing,
you know,
there's no way around it even if you
both sign up for it.
And even if the guy talks shit before
the fight.
Yeah.
It doesn't matter what he does,
it's,
it's A.
Yeah,
I dunno,
I bet it would be really hard to handle
if it was a mismatch,
like say if a,
if you took Iowasca and you had this
vision and then you were supposed to
fight somebody who,
you know,
like in your heart was really fucked.
Like maybe they had bad stand up or
something like that.
And you knew they weren't gonna be able
to take you down.
Like this guy is going to get lit up.
Like,
sorry dude,
you're,
you're under a false illusion of your
abilities.
You know,
that that would make it very difficult.
I would just,
I would imagine.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
you still see guys know,
like they kind of snap out of it when
they have the opportunity to crush
someone whose life lists and the
referees still hasn't stopped them and
then they pull back.
So there's moments there and there's
also moments where you're just,
you know,
you got the blinders on and it's like
this guy,
you know,
I don't give a shit when the rep comes
in.
Yeah.
So it was,
I was asking you think that started you
off this,
uh,
on this trip of retiring because how old
are you now?
Thirty three.
So you're still athletically,
you're still in your prime.
I feel better than I've ever felt in my
life.
Physically,
mentally,
emotionally.
Does it ever like fuck with you every
now and then does there,
is there ever like a little thing and
signing,
like,
come on guys.
If I watch,
that's why I stopped striking.
Like you sharpen the blade,
you want to test it,
you know,
I still do.
I'll do Jujitsu the rest of my life,
but I can't strike if I strike,
I know I'll have that itch really.
You know,
I'll have the itch to spar and from
sparring I'll,
you know,
I'll have a couple of good days and your
who,
who am I testing that against world
champions.
So if I fucking hang right next shortly,
you should be able to apply this to guys
that don't have a belt wrapped around
their waists.
Yeah.
But uh,
you know,
the more I've learned on a living,
listen to like Dr Rhonda,
Patrick and people like that I've had my
face broken twice to act like that
doesn't have permanent effects.
I mean,
it's ridiculous to think like,
Oh,
you know,
it's just an orbital fracture.
No,
the guy fucking smashed my face.
Like there's for sure longterm damage
there that I'm not.
Maybe not feeling it right now,
but that's an issue I have to address.
And the guys only a couple of years
older.
I'm 33,
35,
36 and they start to slow down a little
bit or a.
sorry I was getting audio and just one
of your new.
Did it pop off sometimes I think
disconnects a little bit.
See where the connection is.
There we go.
Okay.
Um,
yeah,
you see if I can notice it in other
people who are just a couple of years
older than I know that's what's going to
happen because it's not.
I mean,
you watch a guy like randy couture fight
and you're like,
oh,
that he's in everyone's face and suck
grinded on dudes.
He even with always been knocked out and
things like that.
He didn't stand in Bang with a lot of
people.
Like there's not,
I can't think of many fights.
Even when when bonner crushed me for 15
minutes and laid on me and didn't
attempt much,
I just took a beating in that fight.
You know,
when I,
when I fought glover,
I had no broken bones,
but that's the only fight where I was
lost leaving octagon.
Bob Bob left and I didn't know how to
get back to the locker room and I didn't
want to ask anyone because I didn't want
a longer suspension,
a medical suspension.
I mean he fucking buried two hooks after
slipping my left right Combo,
one left hook.
Then I throw it again.
He slips berries.
That same exact spot in the temple.
And I mean,
that's the only fight where I literally
did not know where the locker room was
and I was wandering around talking to
people,
making small talk.
Like,
oh,
hey,
how's it going?
Yeah,
that was a tough fight.
Oh yeah.
But I didn't know.
I didn't know where anything was.
And then I finally made have been.
I was like,
Oh fuck dude,
that's bad.
That's really bad.
So you didn't want to ask anybody
because you didn't want a longer medical
suspension.
Yeah.
Whoa.
So that I felt the effects there on the
brain.
I didn't feel the effects from the
orbital fractures,
but I could see the effects.
Right.
And then,
you know,
you see a couple of guys just a couple
of years older,
slowing down a little bit and you learn
about health and being holistic and
nutrition.
And what am I doing for myself to be a
better person?
How can I live,
get more out of life?
Where's my quality of life?
Right.
Well,
if I'm doing that and then that's where
I could drink.
And
if I want to alter my consciousness,
there's a better way to do it than with
that shit.
Right.
And there shouldn't.
It shouldn't be a double edged sword.
When did you quit drinking?
A January sixth.
The last time I drank of this year,
last year in Peru.
Hold last year I was a,
I did a ceremony in Columbia and uh,
the guy was talking about addiction to
things and I never felt addicted at all
to drinking,
but I definitely drank like an asshole
for sure many,
many times.
Uh,
you know,
but he,
he had mentioned next time you drink,
ask what you were feeding.
Everything we put in our body is feeding
something,
ask what you're feeding.
And it just didn't hit me then,
but later on in the ceremony,
it really stuck in like I could see all
the,
the destructive behavior of,
Oh yeah,
let's party.
Let's go balls to the wall.
And you're like,
hey,
yeah,
slapping five and just,
you know,
college,
Spring Breaker,
Asu type Jock,
meathead,
you know,
more and more and more and more,
more.
And then just the destruction,
the toll it was taking on me,
you know,
especially as you get older,
like you can drink like that when you're
young,
but you get to 30 something stops
working,
you're hangovers last a little longer,
you know,
everything.
It's harder to keep up with,
you think it's also,
you're aware,
I think when you're young,
like I remember being hung over when I
was young,
but I was so unaware of how that,
like what I put in,
how it affected my body.
Um,
I just thought of myself as I was in
such a fog of confusion when I was
young.
Just trying to get through life that I
don't think I was aware of my body.
Like I am aware of now.
Like now if I do things like just
changing my diet,
I'm like really tuned into what kind of
effect it's happening,
if any.
I'm trying to figure it out.
I'm much more aware.
When I was in my twenties,
I don't know if I necessarily recovered
from hangovers better,
but I didn't notice it as much because I
was just dumb.
Yeah.
Well yeah,
there's a,
what are we doing now?
Let's get pizza,
you know,
cracked another beer.
It,
get rid of that,
whatever that.
Yeah,
I'm with you on that.
I do feel like there are,
as you age,
your organs just don't keep up the same,
you know,
and I feel like that was a big can,
but really just the,
the reflection for me of seeing how I
behaved with that versus like if I wanna
if I want to feel different,
thanks to the wonderful people in
California that allow medical cannabis,
I can feel different,
right?
I could sleep like a baby and I can wake
up with zero hangover.
Yeah.
And I'm not going to get fat from it.
I'm not going to feel like shit.
I'm not going to underperform the next
day.
Mentally or physically.
You also get benefits from it.
Like many bins.
The antiinflammatory benefits,
the mental benefits of it,
the sensitivity benefits,
the comradery that it sort of
stimulates.
There's a lot of sense of community that
comes with smoking cannabis.
It makes you like a more generous and
nice person and a lot of ways.
But alcohol
man,
it has its place.
I mean I think it's fun in a lot of
ways,
but boy,
it's so abused,
but in,
in this culture and our culture,
it's so.
It's so commonly abused by so many
people and they don't even consider it.
They just pound them just fucking abuse
pot too.
There's no doubt about that.
When I was in college,
I abused pot actually here in Graham
Hancock.
Talk about his relationship under
podcast with cannabis and how Iowasca
showed him that and he quit for awhile
until coming back on the podcast and
spoken with you.
But yeah,
that was great because evil kind kinda
do the same thing for me.
It didn't show me my relationship with
weed that way.
It actually reversed it,
but it showed me that my relationship
with alcohol that way and I don't need
it,
but it also showed me like,
hey,
cannabis is a plant cannabis.
A Dan Hardee said in one of his visions
when he asked,
I have asked about cannabis.
Cannabis is my sister was the answer.
Like this is another one of these is
another teacher.
This is another tool.
This is here for you,
use it,
right,
and I think that if you treat it with
respect and you have an intention and a
reason why you're doing it and it's not,
there's a time and a place for a man.
I just want to get bombed and feel out
of this world or I'm going to push the
envelope and maybe do a mega dose and
jump into a float tank,
which I still need to try.
But uh,
you know,
for the most part you can have
relatively small amounts of things like
that and completely improve your quality
of life with zero repercussion.
Yeah,
because you put in the time and you have
the right intention of this is what I
want to use it for.
Right?
Yeah.
Repercussions that it is something you
have to weigh action versus
repercussion.
And with alcohol,
the repercussions are just fucking
devastating over time.
It's just such a fucking unfortunate
one.
They think they've figured out a way to
create alcohol without any
hangover.
There's been some new research on
something that gives you like an
alcoholic effect,
but it doesn't give you a hangover.
I hope it's not like synthetic weed or
something isn't right.
That weirdo knockout shit.
I always wonder what effects on internal
organs fighting has not just done the
kidneys,
which we know get really fucked up.
Overweight,
cutting.
It's really bad for you.
A kidney stones are one side effect that
some people seem to suffer from
dehydration,
from weight cutting.
I know all those had some kidney stones.
A lot of fighters have had kidney stones
there.
They're really common for guys who cut a
lot of weight,
but also I would just wonder just body
kicks and knees the body and punches.
I mean how many times he get kicked in
the liver before it does damage to your
liver.
I mean if alcohol is bad for your liver,
what does a Shin do to it?
You know,
what is what is a fucking vicious left
hook to the liver?
Just getting by lasted.
Yeah.
I wonder,
I don't know if there's any mean.
We constantly consider the stress on the
brain and the damage to the brain from
head impacts and brain trauma,
but what about body trauma?
I always wonder about that because I've
seen guys get fucking blast today.
Good.
We know that.
It's like you watch a guy eat a liver
shot and the fights over from a body
kick it.
Oh,
he's,
yeah.
Rub some dirt on it and he's fine.
No,
just ended the fight.
No.
So when you look back at your career and
you look back at all these wars and all
these crazy fights that you got in,
do you,
um,
do you think about the damage?
Do you,
is it something you just like put aside
and you know,
that there probably was some done and
just just move forward and stay positive
and be healthy from here on out and I
don't.
Here's one thing that I disagree with
people when they say,
like,
you know,
when we grew up they said,
oh hey,
you have a set number of brain cells and
whatever you lose,
you're not going to get back.
And so,
so we now know that's bullshit.
Like our brain can create new cells.
Neurogenesis happens and the more you
do,
the more new stuff you do,
whether it's learning an instrument or a
new language or taking a different trail
to hike,
whatever,
that helps strengthen these new
pathways.
Right,
and make you smarter and just keep your
brain young.
Yeah.
I don't think for one second that
anything that I'd done in my career
can't be overcome or that I can't really
feel like from diets like this and
supplementing with mcts and different
things like that.
I feel quicker now in sharper now than I
ever have in my life mentally so that
that's good,
but that said,
I don't.
I don't look back and say,
oh,
this did this to me.
I look back and say,
I don't want to do more of that.
Right.
Yeah.
That's a good way of looking at it.
I'm A.
I've talked about this in the podcast
when you heard about Bill Roman Polanski
created that neuro one supplement
specifically because of his football
career,
because all the head impacts that he had
seven memory issues,
a bunch of issues with his brain.
I wonder what's in it.
You know what the product is,
I don't have it here,
but uh,
the uh,
sent me a couple of tubs of it because I
talked about it a bunch of times and um,
it's not something that we sell at on
it.
It's just something I love.
It's just good.
Uh,
and uh,
it's the first neutral pick ever tried
before we created Alpha brain.
And um,
do you stack them now?
No,
I just,
I rarely try neuro one,
but I liked to do different things.
I like to do.
I like to occasionally try Prasad,
I'm way into nootropics.
Yeah.
You tried to interest the Tamar Roxy
arrested him?
Yes,
I have.
How do you like the difference?
Um,
it's hard to tell,
you know,
that's one of the things about like I
had a conversation with a dude last
night at the comedy store.
It was really funny because it was
hilarious because the dude was hammered,
right?
He's like,
man,
I fucking tried off a brain,
but uh,
shit,
I don't know if it worked,
like,
okay,
define worked.
Like what are you doing?
It's just fucking hanging,
hanging out man.
But I don't if it didn't feel any
difference,
I go,
okay,
it's not,
it's not like going to make you smarter
with the idea behind it is if you're,
if you're involved in a task.
Like for me,
here's Alpha brain in nootropics are
really critical for me because I rely on
my memory a lot.
Like when I'm doing the UFC it's a big
factor.
I'm constantly bringing up past fights
and I'm constantly talking about
different situations and transitions and
you know,
this happens when you do that and it,
all these connections that I have to
make my brain.
So verbal memory,
recalling fights,
things like that.
New nootropics are critical for that
kind of thing.
But if you don't have anything that
requires your memory,
how do you know if it's working?
If you don't have anything that requires
you to form sentences on the fly,
how do you know if it's working?
Like so?
I think he just had a silly idea.
I think he thought that he was going to
take this stuff and all of a sudden he's
like,
man,
I know what I'm doing with my life.
Like the fucking light bulb goes,
got uploaded from the matrix with some.
I get it.
I get it all,
man.
I didn't feel it,
but it was hilarious because he was
fucking hammered.
Dude was hammered.
He's like,
I don't know if I felt it.
I'm like,
okay dude.
First of all,
how?
How Shit faced?
Are you right now?
He's like,
I'm poor.
Junk.
Like,
well,
this conversation is going to be weird
anyway.
You know,
you're probably not going to remember
what I'm saying,
but if you had to do something,
it was important and I explained all the
different things that has been shown
clinically in double blind placebo
controlled studies to improve on like
these statistics like you can.
You can show it when you can show with
60 people and you could show that the
people that take it have these effects
versus the people that don't take it
like this is.
This is where it will help you,
but it's not.
It's not going to just make you smarter.
But for someone who relies on their mind
a lot,
whether it's for creativity or for me,
I like to take it now even before I work
out.
I started doing it before a workout now
and I'm noticing less fatigue.
My mind stays fresh longer,
like in grueling longterm workouts,
like,
like a long series of pad workouts.
I can,
I can maintain my concentration like
deep into the seven,
eighth and ninth round of hitting pads.
I don't fade off as much.
Like where I can't remember the
combinations,
you know,
you get so tired,
you're like okay,
what is it again?
Double Jab,
right hand,
left hook,
right kick step,
knee.
Got It.
And then you know,
you're into the left hook and you're
like,
what the fuck is next?
Because you're so tired,
your brain doesn't work that good.
So I think mental fatigue can contribute
to physical fatigue or 100 percent
that's in the his book also talk about
how ketones are,
are pretty much the steady fuel.
So your brain doesn't bonk because
there's an unlimited stream of energy
coming in at all times.
You don't hit the window where you run
out of glycogen in your brain as the
master regulator says,
wait a minute.
No,
no,
no.
We,
we have a very low supply here.
It's finite.
Nothing else is coming in.
So we're going to downregulate
everything and make you perform like
shit right now in an effort to hold onto
what we have.
You know,
you don't ever hit that wall with the
ketones present in the blood.
Well,
I've never been in the key to genic
state.
I don't think I've don't.
Do you ever fasted for anything?
Yeah,
maybe.
Maybe like 12 hours.
I've never done that leg work several
days.
No.
I mean even like fasting is just
deciding.
I don't feel like eating right now,
you know,
I've never consciously decided to fast.
It's just pretty cool.
Yeah.
This is an interesting experiment
because,
um,
I just said,
well,
you know,
there's nothing to lose.
Here is nothing is going to fuck me up.
I'm just going to give this a shot and
see what happens.
I was a little flat yesterday,
like trying to push through.
I'm a elliptical workout was a little
flat,
but nothing huge.
Just a required a little more grit,
you know,
just required me to dig down what I
would rather just get off that fucking
thing.
And around the 35 minute mark,
like the last 10 minutes were pretty
rough,
but other than that,
my brain doesn't seem too foggy.
That was one of the things I was
concerned with that I go on stage and
I'd just be stupid.
Like my brain doesn't work that good.
I'd forget what I was talking about,
but what do you do you blend.
I mean,
do you do bulletproof style where you
blend butter and it just says,
okay.
Yeah,
this is at least some help.
I want to check you out.
Actually I brought in what's check you
out,
bro Bro.
I know I've told you about this briefly
here.
Yes,
you did.
What is,
if you're not,
if you're not checking your guessing.
So one of the things about these
ketogenic diets is you gotTa,
you gotta act like you're diabetic,
you get a blood ketone monitor
these strips her finger or something.
Yeah,
I'm going to.
I'll give you a fresh one here so you
don't need my Yo.
Could I get aids from you?
Maybe from Jenny trip.
Jenny high five.
All right.
So what he's got here is some little
thing that you.
Little pricker.
So what is it like a needle or something
joe?
My little prick.
It's A.
Does it matter lance?
It,
I think is what they call it doesn't
matter.
No.
So what we have here is a blood ketone
strip.
Oh yeah.
You're nice and hot.
Well,
what you want there to be warmth in your
hands or otherwise it's a motherfucker.
Did that make blood?
I didn't even feel that.
That's so weird.
I didn't feel bro.
So tough.
I am Bro.
Little blood on it up.
Well you're going to have to feel
another one here.
God dammit.
I'm going to feel this one now.
I was talking shit.
So what he's got is this little punch
thing.
Almost like little state board move.
Not One.
I didn't feel at all like the other one.
I felt it touched my finger.
That one didn't work.
That's why.
Let me give you a brand new one here.
What's my skins to dick,
bro?
I got double skin thick.
It's not,
you know,
all those years of training and the Maki
Warrah board.
I do a lot of,
a lot of work.
You know what Mackey Juarez folks,
if you don't know karate guys,
they take up a board and it's like sort
of a nailed to the ground or dug into
the ground and sort of locked in place
and the board will give a little bit and
they wrapped the board up with a rope so
it's really hard.
And then he punch it and develop these
callous,
these thick calluses on their knuckles
and then they would go from that to
brick work.
My friend John Lee back in Boston,
he used to have his,
his right,
his index finger and his fuck you finger
than knuckles to those fingers were
fused.
It would be.
It was one big fat rhino.
Not Goal and it was all just from one
big knuckle.
Yeah,
it was all from him punching shit.
That is the last guy you wanted punching
you.
He's punching through bricks and shit.
You know,
your pussy little needle things are not
working on my fucking savage skin.
Is it working this time?
God debit.
Well you got some bitch ass needles you
need to get here.
So basically bro,
I have to figure this out.
Sorry.
So does it work different on different
people's that what's going on for real,
like no bullshit.
Just do people have thicker skin wise
here we can go deeper but I'm,
I'm trying not to be a Dick and put it
on the highest setting and punches into
your setting.
I'm going to flex while you do it.
It's actually the stress of you.
Um,
there's hold on to my hand and shoving
that thing over and over again with no
pain.
I'm like eventually I'm going to feel
So it's like if I just felt pain the
first time but it'd be very minimal.
We've got now you got a razor blade in
there.
I'm putting it in a new test strip.
Just to double check here and explain to
me what this thing is testing for.
There's a little blood on my fingers.
Yeah,
we want more.
Did he feel that?
Barely.
Damn.
Go deep son.
Don't be scared.
I do.
Double check.
Ryan.
I'll Jamie,
she added in
there.
Hey,
I don't like that phrasing
is not working.
Huh?
A goddamn.
It'll allow you to just fucking tapped
this thing.
Okay.
What do you do?
We don't want you to just tap it.
Well,
what is it?
It's a fucking little needle.
Alright,
I'm just shove it in there.
There you go.
Shove it in there.
Pull it out.
Now.
Make yourself bleed a bit.
Give me a drop.
Put her on this bad boy.
So good.
Could be
man.
I shoved that all the way in.
Yeah.
I want you to.
You did.
Oh,
there we go.
That's okay.
Don't worry folks.
Okay,
now we got it.
We got some sweet blood.
Now we've got a countdown here.
Ten seconds.
It's going to tell us your blood
ketones.
So basically you want to be between zero
point five.
Oh,
what does it say?
Low.
What does that mean?
Low battery.
Low battery or low key ketones.
Me?
Yeah.
Really?
It doesn't make sense.
Let's do another show.
I'm bleeding.
I know we got you.
I got some good blood here,
another strip.
Keep it up.
Keep the bloodline open.
Squeezes bitch.
Fucking junk science or go.
Is this bro?
Science Bro.
Bro.
Science bro,
bro Bro.
Alright,
one more test here.
Okay.
Three,
two,
one.
Zero point one.
What does that pathetic.
That's terrible.
You want to be between zero point five.
About three point.
Oh,
and you can go higher than that if
you're like in a really extended fast or
if you take exogenous ketones.
Right?
And then you go above three point.
Oh,
but basically zero point five,
you're in nutritional ketosis given one
more test.
Just to be sure that this isn't bullshit
because I'm not certain.
I believe you're fucking stupid machine.
If it varies,
that's a problem,
right?
If you do it again and you get a
devastating yeah,
that would be a problem.
I don't know that I'm going to get it.
Why is that was about all that blood to
step well,
because it's got to come in a little dry
just to have it again.
What's the negative of being where he's
at at point one?
I'm going to stab it again.
Well,
he's in no man's land,
so he doesn't have carbohydrates coming
in right to fuel his body and he's not
producing ketones.
So did you work out beforehand?
Yeah,
that's why is that just fucking saw.
Should have asked beforehand.
So whatever ketones you have from the
mcts your body's using.
Oh,
that's why your blood ketones aren't
high.
I worked out right before I got it.
That's exactly.
Yeah.
It's going to confirm it here,
but that's exactly why.
So I've,
I've tested,
I've been in Ketosis for awhile and
tested and seen like zero point three
and I'm like,
what the fuck?
And then I listened to dominic
d'agostino.
Talk about that your body will use with
the ketones out.
That's why you're producing.
It's an energy source.
So you work out.
That's going to go to fill your body the
way the blood glucose would have prior
to that.
What is [inaudible]?
It means it's cold.
You know what I'm saying?
What does that mean machine?
I don't know.
It's too cold.
I guess it's too cold machine.
The machine.
The machine is cold.
So what do you do?
Do you heat it up?
Put it in the microwave.
I stick it in my armpit when I'm getting
ready.
The machine?
Yeah,
just right here.
Boom.
Okay.
So warmer,
but it's.
I just prepped myself for nothing that
you did.
Pick yourself for nothing.
What are all these things that you're
sticking in there?
What are all those things?
But these are all the.
The.
This is your trash actually.
That's your little.
I don't know where you've been.
Basket.
That's a.
What are those things in there?
Those are the bits that poke you and
then the test strips,
but any ways you would do this at night
before?
Usually before dinner,
if you're going to have the highest
ketones,
then if you have a night workout then
have at least a couple of soft right now
so I could see what you get.
I'm out.
You're out.
You put the last one,
the last trip to you.
Oh sorry.
You got the written.
Ah,
it's all good.
I've got more at the house,
but.
So you carry these around.
You just do it once a day or how many
times do they do?
There are a few bucks a piece,
so I usually just do them at night.
Um,
when the ketones are highest just to
make sure that I'm nutritionally,
they're a mct oil.
It's usually worn off by that point,
so I can tell like,
am I producing my own ketones as opposed
to just getting it artificially raised
from the MCTs.
Oh,
I see.
Okay.
It doesn't need to be three point zero.
If it's zero point five,
I'm good,
but I will feel the difference when I
reached the one point.
Oh,
between one point.
and two point.
Oh,
one point.
and two point.
Oh One,
I zero point one.
Zero point one.
Yeah,
that's dog shit.
But it doesn't mean anything because you
just worked out.
I'm depressed.
Okay.
So what I'm shooting for though is a
zero point five or higher.
Anything above that,
five or higher.
But you've gotten to one or two.
I've been above three point.
Oh,
from fasting or from exogenous ketones.
But if I'm on a daily basis between one
point.
Oh and two point.
Oh,
then I'm doing good and that means the
foods I'm putting in my body.
I haven't exceeded my protein limits and
Claus Gluconeogenesis or any of these
things like I'm.
I've dialed in my nutrition over time
and that's what it is.
It's just fine tuning.
Right?
Like women can process much more
carbohydrates than weekend on a
ketogenic diet.
Really more.
Yeah,
way more.
I don't know if it's because of the
hormones and the menstrual cycle or
because they're evil.
I have no idea,
but they can get away with way more.
Could it be evil?
Just some.
Some food.
That's interesting.
I wonder what that has meant.
Wonder if it's because they have to
maintain a higher body fat to make lacto
to make milk and to.
It's possible feed the baby and grow.
Titties.
Tossed.
Yeah.
Tosh was in Ketosis the whole time
during the pregnancy and she still had
plenty of carbohydrates.
That's interesting.
And this was so it was a conscious
decision to,
to reach that state during the
pregnancy?
Not at all.
No,
no,
no.
She was,
she.
She asked me like,
Oh hey,
he would see where I'm at and I'm like,
I'm going to waste $3 on you right now.
You're at zero point zero.
I just told you what you're at.
Right?
It's like,
no,
seriously.
I want to see like I feel good.
You know,
it's okay.
So we did it and she was higher than I
was.
Whoa.
I was like,
what the fuck?
But it makes perfect sense.
I mean if you're sending resources to
build a human right,
you know,
and you want that steady flow,
it makes sense.
The body would produce that in a
situation like that just in case you ran
out of carbohydrates.
It is interesting because women,
oftentimes when they're pregnant,
they crave a really fatty foods,
like the crave ice cream and things
along those lines,
but that's not ketogenic,
right?
Because it has a lot of sugar in it.
Well,
there's sugar in that.
Yeah.
Your cravings,
your cravings,
but you want to.
If there's a,
if there's a calling to have more fat,
you want more fat,
that doesn't necessarily mean it's going
to put you in ketosis right now.
If you say,
if you're in this key to genic state and
you eat some carbohydrates,
you eat like a big bowl of pasta,
how much does it whack you out of that
ketogenic state?
Three to four.
Three to four days is typically what it
would take to get back in bed.
Put it this way.
I mean because I've been in and out of
it for as long as I have and because I
work out the way you work out,
you know,
high intensity stuff with kettlebells or
I'll go for a distance from whatever and
then still train on the mat.
That's high intensity when you're
grappling.
I had a Saturday.
We went off the deep end.
I had to gluten free pizzas with Tosh
and we had a bunch of gluten free
cookies and the fricking leader of this
awesome grass fed milk loaded with carbs
and I probably had 500 grams of
carbohydrates.
Grass fed milk is loaded with carbs.
Milk for sure.
Milk is long period.
Doesn't matter if it's aggressive.
It matters if it's grass fed or grain
fed,
but not from a carbohydrate standpoint.
Nobody would think that milk would be a
source of carbohydrates.
What?
Nine to 12 grams per cup,
so if you have a leader in your,
you have four cups,
which is easy to do and read and cookies
that you just had 50 grams of carbs just
from the milk.
Whoa.
How many grams of carbs?
You're supposed to have a day in a in a
ketogenic diet between 30 and 50 during
the Keto adaptation phase,
which is six to eight weeks,
and then after that you can play,
but that's the whole reason you check
because if you're doing 50 grams a day
thinking,
Hey,
I'm going within my limit and you're
still at point three,
point four and fuck with somebody else
tells you that's when it's time to dial
it down a bit.
Or maybe my,
my,
my carbohydrates are fine,
but I'm still not in Ketosis.
That means you're eating too much
protein or maybe I need to add more fat
to my meals.
So the ratio is there and they talked
about it.
John Hopkins,
they were talking about for the,
for the kids with epilepsy,
four to one ratio of fat to protein and
carbohydrates combined.
Now that's pretty.
It's pretty hard to do if you think of
how many you eat a steak,
there's 50 grams of protein and there's
equal amount of fat.
Let's say,
now I have to multiply that by four and
if there's any carbohydrates to add to
that,
then add that to the total for the four
to one ratio,
so you're going to have just ridiculous
amounts of fat to to accomplish that.
What is that device called that you just
use?
It's a blood ketone meter.
I use the Nova Max.
One is the cheapest.
There's a couple other ones that are
five or $6 a strip.
You can get that on Amazon.
The meter itself is only like 20 bucks
and then the strips are a little bit
more and so the strips,
you have to use blood.
Is there another way to do it?
There is a piss test,
which doesn't work at all.
Um,
the problem with that is once your body
becomes keto adapted,
it learns how to better use these things
so they're not excreted in the urine.
So when it tests for acetone,
I think is a cdot Acetate,
something like that,
it's one of the less prominent ketones
to begin with.
So when we convert fat into Ketones,
we have three major ketone bodies.
Beta hydroxy butyrate is the one that
you test for with the blood strip that's
the most 80 percent most abundant in the
blood.
If you do the urine strip and your
body's becoming Keto adapted,
well,
you're not gonna piss anymore out.
So you could be completely in
nutritional ketosis and use a strip and
be like,
hey man,
I'm not in Ketosis.
What's going on?
And it's not that at all.
It's just that your body's not wasting
any out of the urine anymore.
Then they have breast strips or breath.
The breath meter you can blow into and I
can't stand the thing.
I used it for awhile.
I tried to get into it because it's
obviously you can reuse it at 100,000
times and it's still going to be the
same cost,
but uh,
it shows like a,
on a gliding scale,
like an led light.
So green is not in Ketosis,
red is in Ketosis,
whatever.
And then in between you have like green,
yellow and yellow,
orange.
It's all,
it's so fucking hard to read and then
you're trying to figure out,
well I feel,
you know,
it's no,
no,
no.
Just to do the blood,
get,
get me to the 10th.
Exactly where I'm at.
And then you get to all the guests
workout and what exactly is it
measuring?
Like when you say blood ketones.
So what is the number represent?
One millimolar is a measurement of the
Beta hydroxybutyrate ketone millimolar
millimolar.
Hm.
Wow.
So you've been doing this for awhile.
Yeah,
I've read a ton of books on it.
And the thing is,
you know,
most diets people,
I've tried a ton of different diets.
This one you feel good.
You can eat as much as you want.
Like when Dave aspery talks about eating
4,500 calories a day and working out
whatever he said,
15 minutes of fucking month or whatever.
Some nonsense.
Yeah,
here you are going to lose weight.
I'm a better example in the four hour
body,
Tim ferriss talks about the study they
did on calories in,
calories out.
I love this study.
Three,
three groups of people had 2000 calories
a day.
One group a 90 percent carbs,
groupie 90 percent,
Group C,
90 percent fat,
not Shaked out.
Carbohydrate group gained one and a half
pounds a day.
Protein group lost a quarter pound a
day.
Fat Group lost a pound a day,
90 percent fat in their diet and they
lost a pound a day up on the same 2000
calories.
Keep an think about that.
2,000 colors,
not a lot.
So if you had 200 calories of
carbohydrates and you're going to gain
weight from that and you can gain weight
from 2000 calories a day.
Yeah,
that's incredible.
So there's other factors and things like
that,
but there's that just dispels this
concept of all count count calories.
They're all the same,
they're not the same,
they're not the same at all.
How they impact hormones is not the same
hormonal function.
Insulin response when our bodies,
what does insulin do?
Well,
it stores it shuttles things,
right?
So if we are constantly inundating
ourselves with carbohydrates and in this
store mode,
any excess is getting put on,
right?
How do you tell your body to burn fat,
which takes a longer,
harder process when you have this easy
super rapid thing,
it can break down and then use collect.
Politically it doesn't make sense,
but when they talked to the instagram
wizards,
these,
these dieticians in training,
they'll tell you,
bro,
you need fucking carbohydrates to
operate your brain,
bro.
Yeah,
all the science.
I love this too,
and you talk about science and Eddie
Bravo would probably like this to Mr.
conspiracy theory guy.
I love him.
Who pays for that fucking carbohydrate
research?
Gatorade,
Sports Science Institute,
Gatorade Sports Science Institute has
done a majority studies.
Nestle skates,
gatorade is gatorade that's doing a lot
of the studies on carbohydrate
performance.
They're the guys that also proved,
oh,
this is the tipping point for fat
oxidation and an hour even though they
use people that have been in Ketosis for
two weeks instead of two years.
So when you talk about guys like Jeff
and Steve Volvo Cuban doing this
research now since the eighties and
using athletes that have been keto
adapted for awhile,
that's when you really begin to see
like,
Oh shit,
okay,
this can work.
And not just from a physical standpoint.
Like I said,
the thing that I get mostly from it is
the mental.
It's the,
it's the sharpness.
And uh,
dominic d'agostino was talking about how
you can go on way less sleep,
but there's some type of thing that
ketones do with the brain where you
actually are more rested.
Even if you had,
if you were sleep deprived.
So if you had five or six hours of
sleep,
you can still wake up feeling refreshed
and have your sharpness in the morning
rather than being on a heavy
carbohydrate intensive diet.
Exactly.
So they're not sure the mechanism for
that yet.
That's one.
That's why they got these,
these geniuses studying these things,
but I think that there's nothing more
important than when you try something
and you actually feel the difference.
And that's not me saying like,
Oh,
you know,
if you're Vegan,
whatever.
If you're Vegan and you feel awesome,
fucking awesome,
dude.
I'm not going to tell you to change.
I'm going to say,
well,
you should've had this dude.
No,
dude,
you've,
you've dialed it in.
Everyone's different,
but this for me has worked
wonders.
Well,
there's also awesome and then there's
better than awesome.
You know,
like some,
some people say like,
Hey,
I've been on this diet and I feel
fantastic,
so I'm just going to keep it the way it
is.
But meanwhile,
if you added a certain thing to your
diet or added a little bit more vitamin
D or adding a little bit more,
you might feel actually better.
Yeah.
I like your idea of what awesome is.
I think a lot of times it's like if you
ever have water in your ear and you
think everything's okay,
like Ah,
this is how I hear,
and then you know,
like pop,
it pops and you go,
oh,
I could hear like this.
Like you weren't even considering that
you,
you were hearing like shit.
That's what cracks me up about when
people taught and by no means of my,
some type of psychedelic pusher or
anything like that.
But you know,
when I first did Iowaska I was,
it consumed my mind,
Holy Shit,
I want to stand on a mountain top and
tell people about this.
I want every one of my friends to know
about it.
My family,
I want them to try this.
I want them to see what I've seen.
Like I don't want them to experience
this.
And then over time you realize like,
Oh,
you've listened to people tie like,
no,
I really don't want like,
life's just so good right now.
I don't really need to change anything.
Like,
are you a fucking finished product?
You can't improve your life.
You,
Mr. Perfect.
I'm Mr Manhattan.
I'm Dr Manhattan,
like there's no room for getting better.
There's no room for,
for enjoying life more improving really,
whatever,
you know.
And that was just funny to me.
Uh,
that dynamic,
you know,
there are a lot of people that just say
to themselves like,
I'm comfortable.
Why Change?
Yeah,
well people don't like feeling like shit
and they don't like feeling like their
houses in disarray.
And so if they get to a state where they
go,
I,
I'm,
I'm happy right now.
Everything's good.
Like,
uh,
I'm happy being chubby.
Like I've heard that before.
There's nothing wrong with being chubby.
I'm happy.
I'm happy right now with the way I am.
You know,
some people will convince themselves all
they mean.
I oftentimes read things that people
write and I go,
God damn it.
I wonder if this person is expressing
themselves honestly or if they're trying
to get other people to be convinced that
they're okay.
You know how I would lean towards that.
Yeah.
How happy I brought this article up more
than once,
but I read this article written by this
woman who's 70 years old,
struggled with weight her whole life and
she was promoting fat acceptance and
that people are prejudice towards people
that are overweight,
but in fact she's incredibly healthy and
she's so active and she does all these
things.
She's just always,
always been heavy and I'm like,
hmm,
see scientifically that doesn't make any
sense.
It just doesn't like if you're.
If you're eating healthy foods and your
body's healthy,
you shouldn't be storing that much extra
fat.
Just doesn't make any sense.
But she's promoting it in this article,
like if you didn't know any better and
just took this article is like,
well,
this is this one woman's account of her
life.
And by her accounts she's incredibly
healthy.
She's hiking and she's so active and
she's eating healthy,
but she's just fat.
Not,
not really make sense?
It doesn't know something's missing
there.
What
is it?
Well,
I mean,
I actually had this as one of my first
first breakthroughs and my very first
ceremony I was uh,
I was hearing people violently puke
around me and I thought I was like in a
war zone and this is just starting to
kick in and see me.
I've taken the Second Cup Iowasca and it
sounds like people are dying.
And I realized,
oh,
they're puking.
And then I thought,
oh,
that's because these fuckers didn't do
the data.
They didn't eat clean.
Like you have to eat a certain way prior
to it not,
oh,
I eat clean,
I take care of myself.
These people don't take care of
themselves.
And like all that kind of snowballed
into this feeling that I had about fat
people in general.
Like they didn't.
You're not taking care of yourself.
What are you doing?
Why would you do that to yourself?
What would you do to your body?
You know,
like I've always been thin and athletic
and it was easy for me to do these
things.
So when I'm,
when I'm feeling this and I just started
to notice like,
Holy Shit,
what do I feel this way,
why would damn this is getting worse and
worse,
and then I jumped up and grabbed the
bucket and puked my brains out like I'd
never puked before and it came out of
me,
this feeling,
this animosity towards people and I
understood right then like they don't
know any better.
I don't know how they got there,
but I do know that they don't know any
better.
I don't know how to get out of that.
Then even if they do know
intellectually,
they haven't internalized it.
They haven't adjusted.
Right.
There's plenty of things that you can
take at face value.
You here resonates with you and you're
like,
oh yeah,
that makes perfect sense.
Right.
But you don't assimilate it.
Put it into action.
And I think for them,
I don't know,
maybe every time their mom and dad
fought,
they took them to get ice cream cones
and McDonald's.
Oh that's okay.
You know,
come on,
we'll go for a car ride.
It'll be fine.
Here's an ice cream cone.
And then now anytime that under stress
fucking eat ice cream and they don't
even think about it or maybe they do
know and they still say,
I don't care,
I know those ice cream I was going to
make me feel better,
or whatever it is.
I don't know.
That's not my place to be like,
hey you fat,
fuck you.
You know,
like that helped me grow from that.
And that was a huge.
That was like,
oh,
how could puking be good?
And that puking is amazing when you're
getting rid of something like that.
Right?
Like you're letting go of a thought that
you had like this attachment that you
had.
Yeah.
There's,
I mean there's a certain holier than
thou attitude that certain people with
great metabolisms and active lifestyles
will have towards people that maybe they
just,
when they grew up,
they weren't led towards athletics.
They maybe they were bullied.
Maybe they,
you know,
they had poor diets in the home and they
didn't know any better.
And now here they find themselves x
amount of years later a product to a
whole series of things.
I think of the impact it would have
always get picked last for kickball or
something,
handball or any of that stupid dumb
playground games.
You're always picked last.
You don't want to play them anymore.
You're not interested in that.
Yeah.
It's an associate them
with bad feelings.
I was having a conversation about this
with a friend of mine.
She was talking about like how there's
like women that are like angry feminists
that get that truly don't like men.
They hate men and they don't like
masculinity.
She was trying to figure out what that's
all about and I was like,
well,
the parallels got to be.
There's certain men that I know that
don't like women.
They hate women and one of the reasons
why is because they've been rejected by
women their whole lives.
So they associate women with a negative
feeling.
They associate women with rejection.
They associate women with the women,
like as cold hearted leaves them.
It goes with another guy.
Negotiation do that to me,
that bitch.
Well,
it's.
She doesn't owe you.
She's not attracted to you like you've
got.
For whatever reason the universe dealt
you and extremely shitty deck of cards
and that's just the way it is,
but so forever this person that I know
that that has this issue,
his association with women is of women.
The use him,
they want things from him.
His money,
they don't want him and they treat him
badly and he feels like shit and
hateful.
Whereas I have friends that are good
looking guys that for no,
there's no reason.
They were just born good looking.
They just got great bone structure and
you know,
they happen to look good and women are
attracted to them and their ideas of
women are totally different.
Their ideas of women are.
The chicks are fun.
The grade don't get tied down though,
Bro.
You know,
keep,
keep it moving.
You know,
like their ideas of women are much more
light and like women are there.
They're a gift.
There are a great thing in life.
They're not this evil to.
So there's like this association can
often be correlated by what kind of a
relationship do you have with the
opposite sex.
Like if you're a woman and you're
overweight and you're,
you know,
you've always been fat,
your whole life has been like a series
of drunken moments with men who felt
sick after they were with you and you
were rejected and any man that you were
attracted to at wanted to have nothing
to do with you.
So your feelings about men are just as
the angriest assholes.
These Bros,
these douchebags not taking into
consideration like,
well,
what?
What is this relationship you have with
them and what's the root cause of it?
Some of it is outside of your.
If it's just genetics completely outside
of your control,
there's nothing you can do about the way
your face looks or how tall you are,
how short you are,
how,
how big your feet are.
You know,
there's nothing you can do about that,
but the relationship between how,
what you look and how physically
attractive you are sexually,
like people's desire to reproduce with
you.
It really comes down to that in a lot of
ways.
Like what is the relationship you have
with the opposite sex?
Because boy,
when you,
when you go in and really pay attention
to like hardcore,
what you find is a lot of older
successful women and women that are
overweight and not attractive and you
find,
you know,
all sorts of different people in between
there,
but there's an overwhelming number of
people that have not had good success
with the opposite sex,
both from women hating men and for men
hating women and it's like this is an
extremely unfortunate,
you know,
if you look at it that way,
it's extremely unfortunate.
Like taking out gender inequality,
financial issues,
all sorts of issues that also come with
being a male men's rights advocate or a
woman's rights advocate,
a feminist.
There's a,
there's an,
an overall attitude that people have an
issue with when it comes to someone who
identifies with one gender or another
gender and despise the other gender.
Oftentimes it's because their
associations and relationships with that
gender have been negative due to the
fact that they're not desired.
That it's really.
It comes down to them.
And so what are,
what are you doing for yourself?
What is your relationship with that
part?
With the opposite,
sex certainly has to do with that,
but what is your relationship in life?
Do you have this assumption that all
dudes are dicks and they all behave the
same way and in that it's kind of your
mindset can keep you stuck in that whole
just the same.
If you're always thinking like,
this is exactly how they are,
this is it.
This is exactly what it's going to
reciprocate itself over and over and
over again.
So you're always correct.
Yeah,
there's that,
but then there's also the reality,
like my friend who doesn't live was not
my friend anymore,
but who doesn't like women?
He's an ugly dude,
so he's gonna be an ugly dude.
He'd see like porn.
Does he like,
does he like.
No,
it's not like he doesn't like,
he gets angry,
he gets angry.
He's like,
it never has a girlfriend.
He's never been married.
He's just like always like that.
It sounds to me like a guy who used to
work on himself.
Oh,
he definitely does,
but it's also like the girls that he
likes,
they'd never really were into.
I'm just just not attractive.
It's got to shit roll the dice is roll
the dice sucks.
Don't know where I'm going with this.
Well,
but uh,
what I'm trying to say is I'm not trying
to say anything,
but if I was trying to say anything I
would try to say like there's,
there's a lot of complex issues that are
going on with how people feel about
themselves and how they feel about other
people.
And oftentimes what they blame other
people for is really some shit that's
going on with them.
Like they find enemies out there
external enemies to distract themselves
from their internal problems and
failures and shortcomings big time.
Like you find that a lot with haters.
I'm sure you found that when you've read
like horrible shit that people write
about you online like after fights.
Like dude,
I mean look,
the kind of hate that is available to
fighters is some of the most fucking
vicious and personal and emotional.
The people that go after them,
like quote unquote fans.
Yeah.
Every one of them is a loser.
Every one of them,
every one of them.
Every fucking evil nasty Douche bag that
seeks you out to say mean shit to you
after a loss and tweets at you.
You know,
and so,
I mean I've seen some horrific shit that
guy's right.
Two fighters directly after a loss both
on facebook and on instagram,
twitter,
everything.
Those people are all unsuccessful.
They're all failures.
All of them.
That's the only reason why they would do
that.
It's one thing to say,
man,
you know that fucking guy,
he got killed or man,
you know,
that guy got tapped quick or how good is
this guy?
Man,
I can't believe he ran through that guy
like this.
Those are like almost a analytical
discussions that you have with people
where things happen and you didn't see a
comment like,
okay,
Ryan Bader versus rumble Johnson like
that fight without saying anything
horrible about Ryan Bader.
You'd go,
fuck man,
rumble Johnson.
Jesus crushed you.
Just random over man.
Fuck who can take that guy shots and
you,
that's a got a non asshole way of
approaching it.
But good Lord,
I read some Shit online that people
tweeted to him to bader and like,
you fucking,
you should be in a jail somewhere.
You're a monster.
Like you're,
you're looking at this guy like here's a
downed wounded thing and I'm going to
just piss on him.
I'm going to find a spot,
a soft spot,
and I'm a jab him with sticks.
I'm going to see if I could fuck with
his head.
You know,
and anybody who does that,
those people that are doing that,
those haters,
they're all losers.
It's the saddest thing about it.
It's like they're looking at this one
person,
this one thing,
this,
this object that they can attack and
they're externalizing all the issues
they have with themselves,
the imbalances they have,
and then this new ability that we have
to reach people and communicate with
people that really don't want to have
anything to do with you.
You know,
in the real world.
Ryan Bader doesn't give a fuck about
this guy's opinion.
He doesn't know I'm in the real world.
Nobody's saying shit to his face.
Like,
oh my God,
I think that's Ryan Bader.
They run up to him and just blow him
right there.
So cool.
You're so fucking awesome.
You know?
Serious.
Same exact guy.
Boy.
Some hateful people out there,
man.
I know so many fighters just don't go on
social media now because of it.
You know,
you would think photos are tough.
They should feel.
Could toughen up.
Like
maybe you're just a con.
Maybe it's not.
Fighters are tough and they should just
toughen up.
Maybe it's like what you're doing,
you're,
you're being shitty to someone you don't
even know.
Again,
where am I going with this?
I don't know.
I completely agree.
I've even when I,
when we forget who it was,
green flower media did a thing on me
talking about cannabis and cbd and how
many guys in the sport use and just,
you know,
not naming names and Jose conseco
showing it,
but talking about a lot of smoke pot,
like it helps us sleep at night helps
turn off our brain when we're
overthinking shit and you got something
big coming up.
I'm more than obviously now with Usada
and things like that.
There's a lot less,
but back in the day.
Yeah,
fucking,
there was a lot of us out of
competition.
You,
you,
you can smoke pot and in competition
like you can smoke pot up until like the
week of the fight.
And this is good news for me to tell to
tell people.
Yeah.
But yeah,
we did that video and then sure enough,
I didn't know it was going to get
decent.
Not that it went big,
but Bj Penn Dot com ran it and it made
it bigger than it was.
And of course,
and the bottom of the video,
everyone's comments.
I got like two or three guys.
I was like,
oh no,
this is a site.
Oh No.
It didn't help him.
Uh,
with Jimmy men will pay a,
smashed his face and did it.
He wasn't smoked that,
you know,
it's like,
Oh God,
like how does this have anything to do
with,
with what we're talking about here has
nothing to do with anything.
But it's funny.
It's like,
Oh,
let me allow me to,
uh,
allow me to knock it down here.
A couple,
a couple of pegs.
Well,
while we're talking,
you know,
well there's also people that don't
recognize what they're doing and they
just,
they're just talking,
you know,
just making noises and they're not even,
they're not evil,
they just don't realize what they're
saying is hurtful or stupid or idiotic
because they've been given this access
to people that's unprecedented.
There's no training for this.
Like no one,
no one had anything like social media
and our parents' days.
It just didn't exist.
So they never taught us about it.
That's one thing,
thinking about having kids,
like I look at bear now and I'm like,
fuck dude,
we,
we grew up when you had wired telephones
and then we saw a giant,
Zach Morris cell phones come into play
and we had the car phone and like things
like that,
you know,
and then just this evolution over time,
like they're born,
they're not knowing a world without
internet,
without instant access.
Grandparents,
same thing.
They were like,
Bar,
remember when you,
how to take a boat to get here from
Europe.
And then,
you know,
we grew up in a much more technically
technologically advanced era,
but our kids are going to grow up in an
era that's mind blowing to us,
but their kids are gonna grow up in an
era of virtual reality that makes this
look like a joke.
It makes our video games like stupid,
you know?
Yeah.
My Dad's always brag about how awesome
mafia three was.
Listen,
you know,
I had to sit in front of a box like I'm
in the fucking Star Trek Room,
right?
Surrounded by killers right now.
Yeah.
We're probably going to go to places
just like those old swartz and egg or
movies or any of those movies.
You're going to probably go to a place.
You're going to lie down,
they're going to clamp some shit down on
the side of your head and you go,
are you ready,
Mr Kingsberry give me the thumbs up.
If you're ready to launch and you give
the thumbs up.
And usually you're in the avatar world
and you're riding a fucking dragon.
You know what I mean?
That's Gunna happen inside of the next
hundred years.
It's a 100 percent going to happen.
It's just a matter of time.
If they keep going,
we don't blow ourselves up.
We don't get hit by an asteroid.
They're going to come up with artificial
reality that is indistinguishable from
this reality and all of our
entertainment is going to be a joke.
Like,
why would you actually jump out of a
plane and go skydiving when you can get
the skydiving experience with this thing
on your head.
It's gonna make you feel like you did.
That was that movie a
total recall?
Strange days.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
Right.
You could fit into it and they had like
snuff videos where a guy would actually
kill somebody and you felt what he felt
when he killed another person,
like you felt all the neurotransmitters.
Everything was going through your brain
to the heart racing feeling of actually
ending someone's life and you know,
that was the illegal portion of it.
Then they had the legal portion would be
like sex with your loved one or
whatever.
Those kinds of things,
but you could actually tap into the
consciousness of someone's memory as
long as that was recorded.
I think that's going to happen.
I think it's definitely gonna happen.
Uh,
it's just a matter of time if they keep
going,
it's a matter of one invention and one
discovery makes way for another
intervention and another discovery that
compound on each other.
They build on each other.
And next thing you know,
reality is unrecognizable.
Like the reality that we experience
today.
No,
we're talking about these primitive
diets,
primal existence and you know,
how our bodies,
the idea behind all of this is obviously
that our bodies,
it takes thousands of years.
They say about 10,000 years for your
genes to totally change and adapt to new
diet,
new environment,
new lifestyle.
And so we're dealing with bodies that
are primarily adjusted to a hunter
gatherer lifestyle and all this other
stuff that we've added into it over the
last 10,
20,000 years or whatever,
agriculture,
grains,
growing different foods that you could
keep them in storage bins and things
like that,
like grain silos.
That's all fairly reason.
It's and you know,
yes,
you can live like that for sure.
Yeah.
Grains or.
Yeah,
he can eat it,
but what is your body like optimized
for?
What is,
what is your body exists with the least
amount of hiccups?
Well,
it's probably the stuff that's like
super,
like clean and normal like fish,
vegetables,
chicken,
meat,
things along those lines.
The stuff that we haven't fucked with
farm raised this and that.
No,
no,
no.
Farm raised fish.
Eating genetically modified soybeans and
whatever,
you know,
just what's the most realist food we can
put on our body.
Well,
you,
you probably go camping and shit too,
right?
Do you?
Yeah.
You know that feeling you get when
you're out in the woods when you don't,
you don't have any cell phone signal
with any ala mushrooms that too.
Well that's,
that's extreme.
But just even being alone,
like you hear the
nothing,
you have nothing.
You hear the real nothing.
The real nothing of the woods.
It's almost like scary because you
realize like,
this forest doesn't give a fuck about
me.
If a tree falls in your head and you die
right there,
the forest doesn't skip a beat.
The squirrels and chipmunks keep running
around.
The birds.
Keep flying.
The deer keep running.
It's the same.
It literally does not matter does it?
It's been like this before you.
It will be like this.
Unless we fuck it up.
It'll be like this after you.
This is just the way.
If we fuck it up,
it'll go back to that at some point or
something different and it'll become
something different.
Some some new form of nature,
but you go from that to like cities and
cities have this bizarre,
strange,
different kind of life.
Like I was in Manhattan last weekend.
It's fucking awesome.
It's awesome to visit.
He'd go there.
You're like,
you're going from one place to another
in this restaurant that building and
look at this view and Holy Shit and get
on a subway and you're cruising along
under the buildings and it's awesome,
but it's awesome in a completely
different way.
It's awesome.
In this new way,
this new bizarre way that we're sort of
adapting to,
you know,
and this new way is available to us and
wasn't available to people 10,000 years
ago.
This was a mindblower if you took
someone from 10,000 years ago and
brought on a Manhattan and just put them
in like the 72nd floor of one of those
apartment buildings with the crazy view.
Just look out,
look out at the city.
Be like,
what in the fuck am I seeing?
You know,
like you've been to vegas.
You ever been like the top of,
uh,
the Mandalay bay,
that bar that's up there that has the
crazy view and the glass floor.
Oh yeah.
Fuck.
He just look out at the top of that
building.
You're like,
God,
this is insane.
This is like some,
oh shit.
Yeah.
We're experiencing something that no,
no cultures ever experienced.
We're experiencing something that no
generation has ever experienced this.
The technological heights that we're
living in and this ain't shit compared
to what our kids are going to
experience.
Well,
the,
hopefully there are intelligent people
like Marxists on another,
guys that continue to push the envelope
to reconnect.
You know,
like there is a reason that we feel
amazing at the beach.
Not everyone has access to the beach,
but there's a reason we feel amazing at
the beach and scientifically they're
showing now with negative ions and the
energy,
the energy of the earth like it.
It has an impact on how we feel the
beach does.
The ocean does for sure.
The wind coming off the ocean does.
So even if you were on a boat out over
the water,
you're going to feel better just from
doing that.
What does it do?
Like what specifically does it do to
you?
From what I read and I understand there
are an abundance of negative ions,
so from an electrical standpoint,
you're talking again about the human
energy field and auras and shallcross
bro.
Chakra here.
Just going to feel more alive like
every,
every part of you.
I can't describe like from a feeling
standpoint,
everyone has their experience at the
ocean,
but from an electrical standpoint you
would say like you are,
you're clearing out blockages from your
ci,
from a Chinese medicine standpoint,
from a Kundalini and yoga standpoint,
you're going to clear out blockages the
same way and you're just are those
blockages are the is this is a really a
blockage or you just experiencing from
the ocean and it feels good.
Maybe both.
Maybe there is no blockage,
but I'm willing to bet from somebody who
sits too long or has stressed,
you know,
and different things like that.
Like they're very much can be a physical
attachment to emotion and if you've ever
had like bodywork done or somebody you
have a,
you know,
somebody is working to and not and you
all of a sudden start thinking of this
thing that's been bothering you in your
head,
a relationship,
whatever.
That there is physical attachments to
mental and emotional things that go on
in your,
in your head.
So.
So when you get a massage and like the
of like a knot and they work through it,
you think there's emotions tied up in
that?
Not.
Not always,
but sometimes.
Really?
Yeah,
sure.
How's that work?
I don't know how it works.
I don't know why.
I don't know why it would manifest
there.
I don't know why we have an electrical
field that we do.
I don't believe that there's emotions
tied up in knots in your body.
I think when you get rid of those knots,
it relaxes you and that helps you deal
with emotions better.
Okay.
Maybe we went down the wrong path there.
Does that make sense?
Say Yes.
I agree with that.
From a feel good standpoint,
feeling better at the ocean might just
be the view.
But from an electrical standpoint,
there are.
And this one goes back to the studies
done at Ucla,
there very much is an electrical
standpoint that that changes from the
ionic energy coming from the waves
coming from the water coming from the
wind that's above the water,
right?
Because like yoga talk,
they'll say shit to you.
Like this hip opener is gonna.
Make you feel,
feel better about your childhood.
It's gonna.
Open up emotional blockages and you're
like,
I'm pretty sure we're just stretching.
Yeah,
well that's just talking about root
Chakra and exactly how the different
Chakras work,
what they correlate to and things like
that.
I don't know necessarily in a visionary
state.
I can see energy.
I don't see colors.
I don't see like,
Oh,
here's my heart Chakra or something like
that.
But I have seen trees communicate to one
another,
like vibrations coming from the treetops
as they were talking to one another.
What is it like?
What does it look like?
I'm like,
ripples and water,
but it's the air that's rippling and you
could see like perfect circles coming
from the tops of the tree tops.
There was something I tweeted the other
day.
They,
they found that Venus fly traps do
calculations.
They count like for some study they
figured out some,
uh,
some method of measuring the fact that
they actually count things there.
They're doing calculations like that.
They're not smart.
They're,
there is an intelligence plants.
That's just,
that's what I left at.
The argument from vegans on,
from from a consciousness standpoint,
whatever spark we have,
call it soul,
call it whatever plants have it,
whatever.
Whatever animates us and gives us
us.
It's in them too.
Yeah,
for sure.
For sure.
Is this.
It's.
They don't.
They can't communicate in a that we can
clearly understand.
They don't bark at us,
they don't look at us with sad puppy dog
eyes,
but there's something alive in them.
Some strange way that they communicate
and that they absorb energy and life and
that you get that from them.
Let me.
Life eats life.
But that said,
I know many people that have had a
visionary experiences and became Vegan
afterwards.
Yeah,
that's actually,
that's actually really common,
especially in people that do multiple
Iowaska ceremonies and I had a vision.
My only vision I've ever had a bears.
I had a vision of seeing a panda bear
eats bamboo and then I saw a black bear
eating berries and I was like,
Oh fuck,
am I going to be Vegan?
And then I saw grizzly snatch and salmon
out and I was like,
oh.
And it was just the eat the natural,
whatever it is.
There's no right or wrong,
but eat,
take from take from me.
This is mother earth talking to me.
Take from me.
Yeah.
So that's what it was.
It wasn't.
This is right.
That's wrong.
Every animal needs different things.
You know,
there's always these front of Erin
Simpson for I think he posted a giant
gorilla and he's like,
no,
no enough protein in my diet,
bro.
This 800 pound gorilla,
you know.
And it's like,
hey look,
there's no,
there's no right or wrong here.
Like you're not going to go to the,
to the line and say,
Oh,
you're doing this all wrong.
Lion here.
Eat some grass instead.
Like,
come on.
No,
it's fine.
As long as it's from nature,
besides take it is a totally different
animal.
It's not a person like,
you know,
they have a chemical standpoint,
they're going to break down things.
We can't break down with that.
They just depends on added to our debt
so that people love that argument.
Look,
strong grills are bro Roots Shit.
Why don't you go pull shit out of a
swamp?
And eat the stem,
like the chew on stems.
What else do they do?
They also have one inch dicks about
that.
A lot of bad things about being a
gorilla.
I Dunno,
I just think that um,
factory farming is something that people
recognize a lot when they have
psychedelic experiences.
The connection between the suffering of
their food.
And that's real.
I've had multiple versions of that for
sure.
That's as real as it gets.
Multiple.
And that's not fun.
It's not like you watched that and
you're like,
oh,
like you're watching a movie.
It's not like watching the cove and then
Washington,
the cove is hard enough.
But when you experience it,
you feel what it's like.
You embody that consciousness.
Yeah.
And you know,
they know they're all fucking aware.
They're not just these dumb things like
we're going to need some whatever they
provide for me.
Oh you know,
like my buddies on the chopping block,
like I'm stuck here shoulder to
shoulder.
Like you feel you can feel that and tap
into that.
And I don't know how that's going to
stop that.
That seems to be ingrained in our idea
of feeding cities.
It seems like the only way they can
produce enough meat to feed all these
fucking people in these cities,
the way they're doing it now is to
continue this factory farming method.
It's just terrific.
In the movie food inc.
Awesome documentary and the end is hey,
like,
yeah,
it's fucked.
WhAt do we do?
What do we do now?
You do vote with your dollar,
so every time you say,
I can't even taste the difference
between free range eggs and these caged
eggs,
I'm going to save a few bucks.
You vote with your dollar.
Like if you spend a little extra,
you're going to feel better from it,
but also you're going to help change the
culture and they show walmart show
having a organic,
a yogurt or something on the shelves.
Just because there's demand there.
I mean if you go into costco,
here in California,
they have all kinds of organic shit and
costco and mass produced widescale for
cheap because there's a demand for it.
you go there and Arizona and Nevada
maybe not the same,
you know,
like whole foods is going to have whole
foods,
but from,
from giant companies like that they're
listening and it's just a matter of
money that people are willing to spend
it and this is what they want.
They're going to supply it,
period.
Yeah.
But there's also those ag ag gag laws
that keep people from filming factory
farms where they,
you know,
they pack these chickens and these
horrible living conditions and you can't
film it if you film it,
you can get in deep trouble.
Like they did a drone video,
uh,
a pig farm and the pig farm and
carolina,
that Was a motherfucker nasty.
And they show that they were,
they had next to and they interview the
people that are living by their and they
just smell it constantly.
Oh yes.
Funk,
death.
Just death and methane.
I mean the,
the,
that river of piss and shit that comes
out of the bottom of that place and
settles into that little lake that they
had.
And that's not normal piston shit that
is the worst,
most diseased piss and shit.
That's I imagine just living there,
working there rather like someone who
works in there,
like that's the sadness you feel every
day in the smells that you take in
through your nose.
Every day.
Peta was shown a video probably one of
the worst that I actually had the balls
to watch of a how folk was made in
France.
You seeing this just brutal like they
have people are working there and
they're tossing in the chicks.
That's their job to them in the meat
grinder of humans that actually have to
be a part of that process.
So the ones that they don't,
they don't want to like was it males or
something like that.
They get rid of to the female one or the
other,
but it's.
Yeah,
the folk want.
We know what's interesting about fog
wise,
they actually gravitate towards that
feeder.
It's really strange.
I had a farmer explained it to me
before,
like they actually want to be fed like
that.
Go to that feeder and you can grab them
and stick it in their mouth and we.
It looks awful when they force feed them
bum up.
Yeah,
they forced feeding with and just pour
it down their throat,
but apparently it's not that bad for
them.
It's just perception is as far as like
were fattening them up for slaughter and
what if that was you and they put your
mouth around this metal pipe and it's
quality of life,
you know,
but seeing these guys go through the
meat grinder and some of them don't die.
The grinding up of the chicks,
they get ground up and some come out the
other side still alive.
She fog though.
They do that with a lot of roosters.
That's just a fact.
They just grind them up.
Yeah,
it's a fuck deal.
It's a deal.
You know,
I was on the highway once I pass this
truck and it was stuffed with chickens.
It was just madness.
I was looking at this truck,
it was like,
you know,
there were some openings where the
chickens could breathe like some small
holes in the side of the truck and you
just realizing this is like a,
a thing that's packed with life as being
treated like a commodity,
like stacked rocks.
You know?
It's bizarre.
It's bizarre to see a truck just driving
doWn the road.
It's just stacked bottom to top with
living things that are just going to get
either ground up or chopped up or you
know,
doesn't matter.
Going off to death.
Well it's what happened when we made
these city things.
This is also something that didn't exist
10,
20,000 years ago when they had any kind
of agriculture back then.
You grew some livestock,
he killed those animals.
You knew where they lived,
he knew what they ate or you knew the
guy who raised them and it was real
simple.
And then somewhere along the line
someone said,
we need like a costco of farming.
We need to get a big place and stuff.
Everything in there and close it to the
general public so nobody could see and
jab these fuckers with needles and fill
them up with antibiotics so they don't
get sick for all this crazy food we're
giving them.
And boy,
that changed from that.
People are much more aware now and
they're asking for free range food and
antibiotic free food and you know,
grass fed meats and things along those
lines,
but most people can't afford it.
A lot of people can't afford it is a
difference between,
I think I spent a shit ton of money on
that.
I really do it.
A lot of money goes there.
I think knowing where to get your food
from,
like there's certain things you got to
go like,
okay,
hey,
I can't afford that.
To this day.
I don't buy grass fed filet mignon,
it's $25 a pound,
but I can afford grass fed burger,
right?
And free range chicken.
TheY sell free range chicken free range,
organic chicken at costco now,
so I can get it for three 99 a pound.
What does that mean though?
When they say free range organic or they
lie down a field they're allowed to go
around.
Now there's varying levels of that
obviously.
Um,
and it's certainly on a mass scale,
you're probably not going to be the same
as farmer john down the street who's
doing it all natural.
Organic is still going to be organic
feed,
you know,
they can't do any antibiotics and they
can't feed them gmo food.
From what my understanding is.
Well what's interesting to me is that
we're having these conversations now
very frequently.
There's a lot of these documentaries
where it's food inc or king corn or
cowspiracy.
There's a bunch of these documentaries
where people are examining how food is
made and prepared and where it's coming
from and how they're growing it and,
and we're more aware of it now than ever
before.
so some people,
at least some people,
there's a movement to more conscious
choices
and this wasn't around when our parents
were around,
but I don't think factory farming was
around when they were around either.
Was also the difference in the amount of
people.
I mean I've read something about the 19
seventies if there was like a hundred
million plus less people in America in
the 19 seventies.
I mean that's inside my life.
A $100,
million plus more people just here in
the United States.
Go research that.
Jamie,
pull that up is a wizard with this shit.
Nineteen 77.
He was around $203 million.
Yeah,
so It's $100.
Million difference.
That's crazy.
Boy,
we've lucked the fuck.
We just love making babies.
Baby boomers.
All the baby boomers,
kids have kids and you're a part of the
problem now to allow me to.
Yeah,
the good news is the good.
The good news is we were like,
oh,
you know,
three,
four.
Who knows?
Right.
Then if you do that first six months and
you're like,
he might be an only child,
what the fuck did we do?
What do we get ourselves into?
We were talking about this before the
podcast.
Once they start talking about it's a
totally different world,
it gets it,
it all gets way better.
It gets way more easy,
but when they start talking,
they become like your little friends,
you know,
like it's,
it becomes like,
I can't wait to see my kids.
Like after this podcast,
I'm gonna go hang out with them.
And it becomes amazing.
It is amazing.
And they hug you and they talked to you
about school.
And my daughter had this thing today at
school.
She had this little,
um,
you know,
like,
what do they call them?
I want to say a recital assembly.
Thank you very much.
Jamie.
They had a little assembly and all the
kids do their little thing and she had
this big thing that she was really proud
of because she had announced something
and say a part of this little thing that
they were going to do part of the song.
They're doing a song about a different
languages and speaking french speaking
spanish and so she,
she has to go up and do this little
thing.
It's just like this little proud moment
and afterwards she's like beaming and
she's so happy.
She's five and she runs up to me and
jumps in my arms and gives me this big
hug.
The love that you get from that,
the feeling that you get of,
of warmth and of love and connection
with this little tiny,
beautiful human boy is like nothing else
like it.
And then you also recognize,
and this was one of the big ones for me
as I,
as my chIldren got older and I started
putting it all started of trying at
least to put the pieces of it all
together.
I started looking at people like they're
babies.
Like,
oh,
this fucked up dude who's angry at the
world and just devastated.
And just emotionally a wreck.
That was a baby.
That was a baby that just didn't get the
love that he needed or a baby that was
abused or a baby that was neglected or a
baby that was rejected,
like whatever.
It was a fucked up person.
Now in my mind became a baby like crazy
people.
Like I'd see a girl,
you know,
on top of a bar with a fucking chop off,
ooh,
that's a baby.
That's a baby that became that.
Any asshole guy,
you know,
it was fucking screaming at people at
traffic and pointing up,
you'll fuck full.
You're fucking hills.
That's a baby.
That's a baby that became this asshole.
Like it's,
it's just this developmental process
that goes off the rails and into the
forest.
And it's fucked up.
And to get it back on track is insanely
difficult,
insanely.
And the work that's required,
most people are not willing to do dmt.
Most people are not willing to,
you know,
to change their diet and to take yoga
every morning and to fucking get up
early and meditate for 20 minutes every
day to try to be mindful.
Most people are just acting on momentum.
Just scrambling.
And how can I distract myself?
What can I put in front of my face that
will make me think of something else
than what I have to deal with.
That's whY I like talking to people like
you because I know that you're this on
this constant search for improvement and
this constant search for growth.
And I think that talking to people like
you and talking to people that are
filling themselves with knowledge and,
and constantly trying to evaluate their
perspective and maybe enhance their
perspective,
that's inspiring.
And um,
it,
it aLso,
it gives fuel to other people that want
to do the same.
You know,
like people will hear this podcast and
they'll go,
fuck man,
I want to try some of that shit that
kyle kingsbury tried.
Maybe I want to do iowasca.
Maybe I want to read some of the books
that he read.
Maybe I want to try some of the
meditation techniques he's tried.
Maybe I want to do this,
maybe I want to do that.
And I think in doing that,
like in like one person like you who's
seeking these things,
you can start like this cascade.
You start this,
this effect and you started the cascade.
I mean it have to fit.
I've listened to so many podcasts where
I was like,
fuck that guy.
Alright,
let me do that.
I mean even just wim hoff just in that
weeks I heard him,
I don't know,
maybe a couple of weeks after he was on,
I was doing breathwork at the beach and
my buddy was like,
man,
he looked well.
We also had a little,
a laser disc will will say,
we watched the laser disc watched the
laserdisc.
How do I put this in?
Trying to figure out what to read
between the lines here.
I'm tribals syllables.
Laser ll.
There we go.
Okay.
You're talking about mushrooms and I was
like,
this is all this shit.
We've got to keep under wraps.
That's true.
Laser disk.
I get it.
I didn't understand that.
That's something I've never done.
See?
Yeah.
Well
people keep telling me.
Some woman was yelling at me I to show
the other night.
I think
I was listening to you and red band
talked about this and mescalin and
things like that and pod.
And I was like,
man,
I can't believe with having tried other
things that you didn't try that.
Yeah,
there's a bunch of shit I haven't tried.
I heard,
um,
jim fadiman,
who wrote the psychedelic explorer's
guide,
heard him on ferris's podcast.
God his book read it,
and then I saw that maps was doing the
multidisciplinary association of
psychedelic studies was doing a
presentation in palo alto down the
street from me and rick doblin,
the head of maps was going to be there
presenting with jim fadiman like,
oh,
this is amazing.
I got to go.
And once you've had a breakthrough
second delegate experience,
it's amazing.
It can be life changing or it can fuck
you up,
whatever you can take that for what it
is.
A large portion of his book was on
microdosing and in microdosing they were
talking about taking a sub,
sub perceptual breakthrough level.
So meaning like,
I don't see shit,
I just feel and think differently.
Right?
And he said that's really the future of
psychedelic research.
And that's exactly what hoffman was
doing until he died at 100,
two years old.
The guy who developed lsd.
Um,
so we went and I listened to these guys
speak.
And since then I have tried microdosing
with lsd and it is phenomenal.
Like it's almost like a smart drug in
itself,
but you feel good,
you have energy,
you can see why people might do it at a
festival or a concert.
Everything sounds a little more clear.
Like a music sounds better.
If I could,
I could see myself running on it like a,
you really can,
can,
you could still interact.
I can talk to cops on it.
Like you were fine to communicate and to
be,
but you do think differently.
You are connected in a different way.
That's all the rage in silicone valley.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
And I was talking to you right when I
was here and I was like,
oh man.
Oh man.
That down with a mescalin not down with
the lsd.
Huh?
Not that I'm not down.
The problem with acid is the people that
want to do acid with you.
You don't want to do acid with them,
you know,
like,
yeah,
I gotta go dude.
It's all these weird people that are
pushing it and they want it.
Like dunkin is the only guy that I know
that gets real acid and we've sort of
made a loose commitment to me and him
getting together and doing it one day.
I want to hear about that,
that's for sure.
Awesome.
I'll definitely talk about it.
But,
um,
the,
the thing that I've been really into
that I get these big breakthrough,
I'm objective moments.
Introspective moments is edible pot and
psych and um,
um,
flotation,
flotation chambers.
There's something about sensory
deprivation with the edible pot.
It creates this bizarre sort of,
um,
hallucinogenic state,
visionary state that's very unusual,
very unusual from a visionary
standpoint.
Do you,
when you see obviously you're in pitch
black,
so anything you see in your mind's eyes
What you're seeing,
would you say you see like more of the
sacred geometry or the kaleidoscope of
shapes and things that you do from dmt
or do you just see like a memory or you
relive something or maybe you see
something from that's been on your mind
and you live that moment for a second
and then pull back out of it?
well,
that's one of the fascinating things
about it is the experience is incredibly
flexible.
Whereas like the experience
of dmt,
although it varies,
it's also very dmt.
Like when you do dmt,
like,
aw,
reality dissolves and you're there.
Like the last one that I had was very
strangely,
there was these gestures that were
giving me the finger.
They kept giving me the finger.
I'm like,
what is this about?
And then I was trying to figure out like
what are they trying to tell me?
And one of the things that were trying
to tell me is,
uh,
it,
it was almost like a reaction to not
worrying what other people think of you
or not worrying about people fucking
with you or not.
It was almost like,
what do you care?
What do you care?
I'm doing this to youtube,
what do you care?
What do you care?
Like,
why,
why are you tripping about this?
And then I kind of got it in the trip
and then they'll like shaking their
head.
Yeah.
And there's this weird fractal thing
that's constantly going on,
but every time I do it,
it seems like these lessons that are
wrapped up in these visions with
communicating entities,
whatever the fuck they are,
where they're figments of your
imagination,
whether they're real,
there's always lessons in there.
And these lessons are always pertaining
to either a personal hiccup that I got
going on or something that I'm
struggling with or trying to overcome or
something that I'm constantly focusing
on and trying to understand better.
So it's like,
let me help you out there,
dude,
fuck you.
And you're like,
these gestures,
we're all going,
fuck you.
It was like,
why are they going to fuck you?
I was trying to figure out what it is.
It's like it's almost a,
an,
an inoculation to hostility.
Like their like letting you like what?
Why are you even taking this in?
Like you know,
what,
why are you even concentrating on that?
This is pointless.
There's so much more.
And then when you get past that level,
the experience in blossoms into some new
level of experience.
So the dmt state is very dmt like.
But the cannabis,
the edible cannabis to the 11 hydroxy
metabolite state that you get from
edible cannabis,
which is dose per dose,
five times more psychoactive than thc.
That's why people when they eat it,
they trip out and like,
oh my god,
so many laced it with something.
No,
it's very much like an intense
psychedelic when you eat it.
That's why you got to be careful and not
eat too much.
Like people that fucking freak out and
panic attacks.
It's because it's strong as shit when
you eat it.
But in the tank,
sometimes I go on these Journeys that I
like,
I'm in the forest and I can hear other
languages and I understand them and I
don't know what the fuck they are and
sometimes I'm a part of a like a ball of
yarn that the universe is made out of
and each individual fiber that's in this
gigantic strand that's a part of this
wrapped up ball of yarn is all the
individual atoms that make up being a
person or a tree or a book or a rock and
all these different things are
intertwined and it shows you the fractal
nature of reality from the lowest
subatomic particle to the biggest planet
in the solar system to the biggest
galaxy in the universe.
And it just goes out there and this very
strange and humbling and bizarre like a
volt vulnerable vulnerability inducing
state.
And then it'll go from that to cartoons.
Fucking like would to been like neon
cartoons banging each other and
producing a bunch of other neon
cartoons.
Cartoons.
Fucking dude.
This is not just cartoons fucking,
but they're like neon.
They're like made out of like neon
lights.
And they're banging each other and
they're,
they're becoming other ones that having
that god damn thing in my basement is a
blessing and a curse at the same time
because,
uh,
it's,
it's a blessing and that it's great that
I can go in there anytime I want,
but sometimes one crazy trip,
I'll just leave me like baffled for
days,
but the relaxation aspect of it too.
So sometImes I'll go in there on the
couch and just chill out and just float
and I get out of there.
Man.
I feel like I'll be in there and while
I'm in there floating,
I like push down to my hips and my back
would go pop,
pop.
Like everything's like loosening up
because of all the,
all the epsom salts in it has magnesium
and magnesium is great for your body.
It's one of the best ways to absorb
magnesium is through the skin.
That's why an epsom salt bath is so good
for your musCles and there's no epsom
salt bath can fuck with the tank.
Not even close that thousand pounds of
salt.
No massage can fuck with the tech.
Yeah,
go ahead.
Amazing massages.
But when you come of the tank,
you do feel like you're floating four
hours after you just feel high.
So you've been in the tank,
you just haven't been in a tank on
anything.
I haven't done anything in the tank.
Not yet.
And that's like a smoke a little.
Just a little sister.
My brother,
my brother have a good now there's
plaCes available in the bay area.
See,
back in the day there was a lady in los
gatos so it wasn't far from me and she
sponsored me for fight camps,
so I would go in once a week or twice a
week leading up to a fight.
Oh really?
Interesting.
And it was amazing.
It was a great.
That really got me into flotation and
then she ended up moving down to santa
cruz,
which is a little hike for me.
So I have been an oakland different
places.
They have them set up now and um,
there's a couple places that allow the
bin night run,
so you can go in at midnight and stay
overnight.
So you do it overnight,
float all the way until 6:00 AM or 8:00
AM.
Yeah.
Someone's in there with you.
Oh,
they have someone working there,
but you're,
you know,
you can go in there and ben just
sleeping it basically so crazy.
Hippy.
They think they know what's up.
I think they know what time it is.
Oh,
so it's just a matter of what um,
you know,
what do I.
That's why I was like,
I was curious.
I wanted to ask you about that.
Like what do you,
what,
when you say visionary state,
what are you getting from that?
Well,
when you say like,
sometimes I'm in the woods.
There's this,
that's all the answer that I need.
That's for sure going to happen.
I've done mushrooms in them.
That's pretty intense to how many grams
now?
That many.
Like three.
Okay.
See,
I found like,
I mean that's a lot,
but not like.
Yeah.
I feel like between a,
a,
one gram to four gram dose,
I get a lot of feeling from it,
but I don't necessarily get to a
visionary state of five grams,
but do it in silent darkness.
Like where do you,
where are you doing it?
I,
yeah,
if I guess it would be,
it would be different there.
The visionary state,
to me it occurs with the eyes closed.
That's where the real visions Come and
most of the time when people are doing
it,
they're out in nature and they were like
the first time I ever did mushrooms we
did it like in the woods and his
beautiful manage felt he felt like the
vibrations of the earth as if it was
like loving you and breathing and like,
like it was you felt like connected to
it in a way that I'd never felt before,
but there was no,
not much visions because you're out
there.
I mean it seemed like alive and
everything seemed strange,
kind of pixelated and everything sort of
had like a,
like a geometric pattern to it in a
weird way that you never experienced.
Tasha and I did have had him at the
beach and we had a monster dose one time
after iowasca is really kind of improved
other psychedelic experiences for both
of us because we can let go.
Yeah.
Like some of those lessons of not trying
to control it,
you know,
just going with the flow and,
and um,
and then also from a stomach standpoint,
like a lot of people that eat mushrooms,
it fucks her stomach up.
It used to fuck my stomach up,
but after you've purchased from iowasca,
like it's nothing for me to have a bunch
of mushrooms and my stomach's never did
that to me,
to my stomach.
I don't know why this is really is.
It's,
I think it's very personal deal.
But uh,
we had seven grams each on the beach and
that's the most we've ever taken.
And I went when I was face up,
she's 110 pounds too.
So she's the real trooper.
But when I was face up you could see
things that I wouldn't normally see
like,
uh,
seagulls in a v formation I could see
like laser beams connecting their wings.
And then it was like fractal,
like you would from a dmt trip.
but every color of the light spectrum
was connecting their wings as they
flowed through air.
And then the sound of the ocean is
different.
But then when I went face down and bears
buried my face in the sand,
then I had complete visionary state just
like dmt or or iowasca even.
Yeah,
I would imagine.
And probably last a long ass time to
long time.
That was a long day at the beach.
It's probably a couple solid hours of
visions then,
right?
With that kind of dose.
Yeah.
On and off.
There were some.
Yeah,
there.
I kept seeing that initially I kept
seeing like this,
like a group of people like kind of
eyeball on us that I was thinking like,
are they going to take our shit?
Like are they going to try to steal or
am I going to have to fight someone?
Like this is weird.
This is a place not a lot of people go
to.
And I kept seeing that and then I had to
take a deep breath
and tosca You like feel me,
you know,
feel like my energy.
She could feel what's going on.
She's like,
are you okay?
Like somebody kind of come know whAt do
you,
what are you talking about?
She's like playing fucking sea turtle
bugs.
Shit.
Whatever,
you know,
like she just doesn't have it,
and she's looking over at me and am I
okay?
And she's like,
seriously,
you're fine,
don't worry,
you're fine.
I was like,
okay.
And I put my head back down and it kept
seeing.
Didn't like this young kid kind of comes
through the crowd,
like he's going to challenge me and he
walks down like,
oh fuck,
I got a defender.
So I got to fight and I know how fucked
up I am.
Like I can't believe we had to defend
myself.
And I'm like,
it's playing out in my mind all the ways
that I'm going to have to fight this
guy.
And I realized right then like I stand
up open.
I was like,
oh fuck,
it's just a vision.
And I was like,
my heart's raciNg.
And I'm like,
why would I think that?
And then I realized every fucking day of
my life since I was a little kid,
I played that out.
Anytime someone gives me a dirty look or
it says like we're from whatever being
picked on as a kid,
bullied that kind of shit.
Like I always play that out,
like how am I going to have to fight
this guy?
Am I going to have to fucking defend
myself?
How's it going to play out?
Oh he's,
he's got a long fucking neck,
I'm going to take us back and choke them
out,
whatever,
you know,
what I'm saying?
But,
but it just showed me how silly this
dumb ass mind game that I would play and
I would go down the rabbit hole on a
fucking daily basis sometimes.
Like,
like just playing into this thought of
negativity that had no space for me and
it does me no good to play that out.
Like,
that's fine because then I'll do this.
No,
no,
none of that shit.
I'm wasting time and becoming
emotionally attached to those thoughts.
It's not just,
oh,
I'm thinking about this.
I'm feeling like I'm going to fight
right now.
That fucks you up.
That turns you into not your best
version of yourself.
So that vision from mushrooms was just a
fucking game changer.
It doesn't stop me from having those
thoughts,
but it allows me to catch myself.
I'm aware of it.
You know the pattern still exists,
you just don't entertain it.
I don't entertain it.
I can see it and let it go.
Like when they talk about meditating,
oh,
if you have a thought,
just recognize the thought and let it
go.
That's easier said than done.
Now I've had time to digest and
assimilate that and especially bouncing
or bartender and the guy's being a dick
or whatever.
It's very easy,
much easier for me to be like,
I don't have to entertain.
The guy swings at me.
Then it happens.
That's worried about you're not going to
not know when it's getting there,
but there's no need sometimes.
The things.
I always say that about cops,
like sometimes I bet certain people,
whether it's the people that deal with
the cops or certain people that are
cops,
things happen that don't need to happen
because people have these ideas or have
these patterns that are playing on in
their head and for a comp I would
imagine it's got to be incredibly
difficult because you're dealing with
all these people that are constantly
breaking laws and violating things and
you're supposed to enforce them and
you're constantly worried about getting
shot and getting home to your family.
You're constantly worried about pulling
some guy over and he's got fucking 20
pounds of coke in the back of the
machine gun in his front seat and you
don't know because there's windows are
tinted elixir.
Roll down your window
and you get your hand on your gun.
You're like,
what the fuck am I getting into here?
And then these patterns that people
have,
whether it's as a police officer,
as a person getting pulled over by cops,
they can change the way you interact
with people and change the circumstances
of the day and and turned a tragedy into
a nothing or nothing into a tragedy.
That's the lens.
That's the filter you see through all
your interactions come out of that
patterns,
man.
And sometimes the beautiful thing about
psychedelics is that it allows you to
get outside of you and look at the
ridiculousness of you.
that's one of the biggest.
yeah,
that's it.
You're talking about change and
transformation and things like that.
That's been my biggest catalyst and
seeing the way I behave and that doesn't
mean that I'm mr.
Perfect.
And then I don't get angry or I'm not a
like,
yeah,
no sleep for six months with a child.
We've,
we've touched it.
I've had though.
That's the.
Anybody who's had a kid.
No.
It's like that's fucking a real
struggle.
There's no perfect people,
man.
This doesn't exist.
That's this idea that there's a perfect
person.
This is an enlightened being.
There are people that choose to go down
certain paths that will lead to them
making better decisions,
lead to them living a more harmonious
life,
but you're just a monkey.
You just some fucking talking ape that's
on this planet filled with
contradictions and chaos and you're
trying to get through like all of us are
and who's going to be interrelationship
drama in work,
drama on and fucking community drama,
neighborhood drama,
and you're gonna.
Sometimes you'll be too stressed out or
too tired or too distracted or two too
overworked or whatever the fuck it is.
You're going to have a bad reaction to
those things.
It doesn't define you.
That's a real problem that people have
though,
is one bad reaction.
Like you yell at your neighbor and your
neighbor,
fuck you and the cops come you piece of
shit.
I'm going to slash your tires and fuck
you and these things that have.
I got a buddy of mine last night,
explained to me something that he got
into his with his neighbor and uh,
he accuses neighbor of slashing his tire
and he,
he fucking know,
like,
yelled at his neighbor.
And then he got his car picked up by
aaa,
they changed the tire.
they go,
no,
you hit a curb,
curb and deflated his tire.
And he was blaming his neighbor,
pull the spear out of your mouth right
now.
Created this whole fall.
And he was like.
And I was like,
he's a comic.
I was like,
are you going to talk about this on
stage?
He was like,
I can't.
I'm too embarrassed now.
I'm not ready to like,
this isn't funny to me.
Yeah.
He's like,
he's telling me because we're friends,
we're both laughing.
I'm like,
fuck man.
Did you apologize to emulate?
Not yet.
IT was like,
god damn it,
I don't know what to do.
Like because his neighbor would get
pissed because he parked in front of his
house and the guy had trash cans and
he's like,
you park it too close to my trash cans.
I can't get my trash cans.
And I was like,
what?
And so he goes out,
he finds this note on his car and his
tires flat.
And he assumed that the guy wrote the
note tire.
Yeah,
he's a good guy.
But he fucked up,
you know,
like fuck ups,
but if you took those fuck ups and you
like,
it's all,
you concentrate on your whole life all
the times you fucked up.
Like you're like,
oh my god,
I'm a fuck up.
Like no,
you just a person man did.
That shit will repeat itself.
Like you will fall into the path of that
instead of having the humility or at
least getting a little help from an
outside source that allows you to take a
step back,
pull the blinders off and see what's
going on and be like,
you know what man,
I fucked up.
That's also whY objectivity is so
important and introspective thought is
so important because sometimes people
just make excuses for everything they
do.
Everything they do,
they have a fucking excuse for.
So you never get the lessons and you
never get the growth.
He never learned.
You just,
you just constantly repeat,
constantly repeat.
And then one day you're a Bitter old man
yelling at these kids to stop what
they're fucking rock and roll music and
your goddamn car.
Driving down my street,
we got loud muffler and that's the same
shit.
He knows his patterns stayed.
They fall into these patterns and then
they die.
And these never,
never corrected enough.
Never.
Just never got it.
Never got it right.
No introspection.
If there's no quiet time.
Yeah,
we're running out of time.
What's it sober called?
Kingsborough.
You bad motherfucker.
This is fun,
man.
Fuck yeah,
we did this.
I loved it.
so I gotta get one of those bad boys and
get my millimolAr millimeters.
What does it millimolar.
Chella mowers.
Checked and blood.
The blood ketone meter.
So let's do this again man.
I think we could probably do this for
fucking hours and hours and hours to
come back again.
One more time.
A king's bu on twitter.
If you want to get ahold of cow.
I put that on my twitter and uh,
that's it.
Thanks brother.
Appreciate it man.
Thank you very much brother.
Alright my friends,
that's it for the week.
Oh,
we'll be back with a fight companion
saturday night.
Brandon shot brian callen,
eddie bravo and me.
So that's a saturday night.
We'll be here for the ufc fights.
All right,
my friends.
Bye bye.
Listening.